Mr Senator how are you so I called him I
said you know you're going to have to
change that you Mr happy for
you l for work
session this is going to be a little
challenging to keep this moving because
these
guys
sent me a text this morning saying U
good morning I'll be in at some point to
remove stuff from the office she doesn't
have anything in the
office a couple
things
yeah
lapt just so I can look up
bills
you're okay I
start
need right good morning everyone the
time being 9:33 we'll get started with
the work
session and I'm going to open the work
session first for
HB
and while we will cover each bill
individually I do expect that there may
be some crossover here the I've listed
the first three bills the first three
education bills um 1514 1563 and
um while we have uh some representatives
from education and
doj um and
also HB 1655 which is listed a little
further down the page here um we'll
probably I'll probably pull that further
up while we have those same members here
at the same time so they don't have to
wait through the whole morning to get to
1655 okay do I first do we have any
comments on um
1514 CH yes representative
PL to me this is is going to have to
happen uh be right now I I believe the
uh swept we keeping the uh letting the
towns keep in excess is probably
unconstitutional my only question is
whether it has to happen now or part of
a
comprehensive uh plan uh come coming out
of a special committee set up to handle
Statewide education property uh no
Statewide funding of uh School schooling
education what so whether the timing is
propitious or could wait that's my my
question it it may make sense for me to
call up Mr Garland uh from the
um doj to
get some information as much as he can
give on where we stand um in general um
because there's a lot going on with this
issue
obviously
there we go thats all right um all right
thank you chairman um I'm here from the
the Department of Justice my name is Sam
Garland I'm um senior Assistant Attorney
General there and I've been involved as
a litigator in the school funding cases
we currently have pending um and as
representative Janan noted there are
some things I I certainly can't talk
about we're in the middle of of that
litigation and and I can't you know
weigh in on on certain aspects of of
of that but I can provide if it'd be
helpful to the committee an overview of
where we stand in the litigation there
are two cases and and I think um they
they focus on distinct things um and and
where the process currently stands and
and you know the rulings that we've
received from the trial court so far if
that would be
beneficial um so so there's uh a case
that's colloquially colloquially known
as conal it's kukuk Valley School
District it's it's the older of the two
it was filed in 2019 and that case is
focused principally on base adequacy so
that's um the amount that's in
1984a I believe is the is the statute um
and it's the per pupil cost there so
that's not focused on the swept issue
that we're we're talking about today
it's focused on um the the the base
adequacy amount um we had a trial in May
uh and judge rof the superior court
judge has uh has declared that the
amount that's currently in the statute
is unconstitutional it's not sufficient
to fund an adequate education as as he
viewed it um he has also directed
payments be made uh to to a higher
amount that he identified in his order
um that matter is currently um there's a
motion to stay that portion of the order
pending at the New Hampshire Supreme
Court um and and that motion remains
pending um and we've represented
publicly that that the state does intend
to appeal the ruling to the New
Hampshire Supreme Court to get to the
Supreme Court to weigh in definitively
on on on the issues in that case and so
that appeal will be forthcoming in in
the next couple of weeks and then it
will be briefed and it will take um
likely several months for the brief and
an argument and resolution of that case
um there's also a case that's uh that's
Steve Rand versus State of New Hampshire
that case also has um an adequacy
component to it that is still pending in
the trial court but it also took um it
had a claim that directly focused on the
swept and it it made the argument that
because towns um there there really two
arguments but but the main one um being
that because towns are allowed to retain
excess swept uh under the current
statutory regime which which reflects an
amendment in 2011 that allowed that to
occur um that violates part two Article
5 of The Constitution um because it's
not an equal or proportional tax and so
we brief that on Cross motions for
summary judgment just arguments by
lawyers on on the legal arguments there
um and the same judge judge rth has um
has agreed with the plaintiffs that the
swept as currently administered is
unconstitutional um the there is a
coalition of uh of towns um former donor
towns that that intervened in that case
they've already filed a notice of appeal
to the Supreme cour Court um we are
likely to appeal that case as well um
there's no motion to stay at the Supreme
Court currently pending in that case um
and so that case is really the one that
focuses most directly on the issues that
that I think the bills in front of you
today are concerned with which is the
question of the Statewide education
property tax um and and really for for
at least 1514 I believe um the the
question of excess funds um uh and as I
understand it 1514 would go back to a
world that is pre 20101 that would have
the any excess funds um be remitted to
the education trust fund um where they
would be um you know they they that they
would be reallocated in some way under
under the legislation and so the the law
would shipped back to a world that that
um existed prior to
2011 I'm happy to take any questions
that that thank you that was helpful um
representative Aly uh I'd just like to
make a slight correction I think we put
in what was repealed in in 2011 we put
in around
2008 um it was was a a late Improvement
and it I believe it it was why the New
Hampshire Supreme Court decided to
release strict
scrutiny which is what allowed 2011 to
happen going
backwards representative PL
uh perhaps you could aine on the
question I asked whether we should pass
this now or wait for more comprehensive
solution coming out of a special
committee sorry representative um I
didn't mean to interrupt you um I I'm
not comfortable opining on that specific
question um I can provide some context
for it I I do think the question whether
to uh whether to go forward with
specific legislation is really uniquely
Within your per perview to to think
about and it's something that from kind
of a litigation standpoint I'm I'm
uncomfortable um providing you know
specific opinion or advice on that what
I will say is uh the swept issue that's
identified in Rand is a specific issue
that that didn't come up in conal it's a
question about how the tax is
administered um representative Aly is
exactly right and I did leave out that
that previous context not um not
deliberately which is that when the
swept was was created basically when it
when it went from a state education
property tax to the Statewide education
property tax it was part of a holistic
um reassessment of of the education laws
in the state that occurred in 2008 uh in
in and around the londonairy um
litigation that happened then so it
didn't happen in isolation then but it
is a specific question that's uh that is
raised only in one of the two cases that
are currently
pending representative
Ames good morning
um I've got I have a couple of questions
but first I'm surprised that there's no
stay uh being requested for the Rand
case and um what is the
what there's an an order for immediate
action in that case as I understand it
um and um no request for a stay is there
time for a request for a stay still or
what
what what should be done in the meantime
absolutely so again I I I have to be
careful not to get into kind of the
legal strategic thinking um or or or
divulge work product or or attorney
client Communications what what I can
say about the issue in Rand is we we did
move for a stay in the trial court which
the trial court denied um it was a
motion that was joined by the Coalition
or the Coalition filed a similar motion
that the trial court considered and
rejected the coalition has filed the
appeal and um it is represent it
represents a group of towns that I think
have a perspective that's different from
the really Dr but the state more
generally on the administrative um
burdens with respect to changing uh the
the current way that the swept is
administered for for Dr there are
certainly questions around that and and
I think it's something that we are
looking long and hard at for the appeal
and whether if there's a request for a
stay coming from the Coalition um you
know what what our responses to that but
terms of how it affects uh particular
Municipal budgets how they that process
which which I know as you know plays out
over a matter of months and there's
significant um you know significant time
that needs to go into considering what
sources of revenue will be um and how
they're going to be allocated the
Coalition is in a position where it can
speak about that on a Town level in a
way that we can't um and so that that's
not a direct answer to your question but
it but it kind of gets into a little bit
the order of operations that we are we
have here in the interest that
play okay well we'll leave that I'm
sorry I um we'll leave that um it's all
pretty murky and we've got to work our
way through it in the meantime we've got
all these swep bills is is not just one
um and um with regard to the swept bills
there is an additional bill that I think
I should mention as context that relates
both to conal and Rand that I just
learned about early this morning um
filed by representative
emerik um in a work session yesterday on
House Bill
1583 which is one of the bills that
passed on the house floor I think a week
ago um providing
additional um an an increase in the
base number from 40 can't do the numbers
by about $200 or
$300 uh per pupil um and the amendment
by representative Emme which is uh
significant uh would increase the per
pupo base cost from
$4,100 to$
7,356 And1 which might bring a bell with
you
um in the con Val case is that's the
very number that judge rof I believe um
um came down upon and uh and then it
also raises swept from uh a tax that
produces $363 million to a tax that
produces
$773
million uh so
it I guess by my math that's more than
doubling the um amount produced by that
tax uh which I I understand would
result um I haven't checked this myself
but an an increase in excess
swept of about
uh uh $90
million so that's a background I that
may go nowhere but it's part of the
swirl of uh of
uh efforts to respond to this situation
I think that we've got to be aware of as
we go through this um and I don't really
expect I'm sorry to be commenting rather
than uh questioning I'm not sure it's
much you can say in response to this or
maybe you're aware of this
activity so representative Ames I I
became aware of of the actual bill this
morning as well uh it's not something
I've had even a chance to look at but my
understanding is the same as yours in
terms of of what it does what I can say
is I haven't studied it we haven't you
know had a chance to to think about what
effect it would have on the litigation
um but I as always would be happy to
come over if if this uh committee has a
has a work session or a hearing on it to
to weigh in uh where at a time where I
could be more prepared than I am today
but I am aware of it and it's something
we'll be keeping a close eye on as well
okay I I'll leave it at then I I have
copies of this amendment if I if I
should pass it out I will would you like
me to do that of the amendment to 1583
the 1583 the one I just spoke about okay
what committee is that in that's in
finance Finance
okay I pass around sure just just uh
their information Y where the hell
is yeah oh you got it too of
course representative
Southworth thank taking my question um
I'm thinking of context and perspective
so if we do pass these bills um the
legislators making a point or taking a
stand or whatever um but everything can
still be appealed so I'm I'm just
wondering whether we pass these bills or
not um it seems like it will end up in
the
court it's certainly possible
representative
um so so one thing that I haven't
assessed and wouldn't feel comfortable
weighing in on now is whether if these
bills passed or ultimately the bill that
representative Ames just spoke to um
whether that would what effect it would
have on the litigation and ultimately
the question would be you know would it
moot the litigation or would it change
um the likelihood of appeal that's a
complicated question it's more
complicated than than it might seem at
first blush and we'd really have to dig
into that um what I'll say more
generally is
um
that there there's a there's a
significant question that I think has
existed in in this line of decisions for
a very long time between you know the
Court's role and and school funding and
the legislator's role um and it's a
question that is really Central to every
one of of these cases and so the legisl
and it goes a bit to to representative
jian's question at at the beginning um
or maybe it was representative pl's
about uh whether to move forward with
let litigation or legislation while the
you know the cases are out there and and
what I would would say to that is the
the litigation responds to the
legislation but but this is a body that
you know that is a separate body from
the the court system that has to
consider the policy implications and and
and the positions it wants to take
separate from that is I shouldn't say it
has to but that that's kind of my
perspective on it is they are separate
and
um they're distinct they're related but
distinct that's helpful thank
you representative fellows thank you Mr
chair um I'm not a lawyer
but I did read you know some the some of
the conval decision and the Rand
decision and my um perspective of the
Rand decision was that the well actually
the judge had two had two cases and when
he made a ruling on the Rand case it
seemed to me that he was taking it
strictly from the perspective of this is
a
tax and because all of his um arguments
and reasons for his decision were based
on tax law and not they didn't it didn't
seem to be tied to the fact that the
swep is a major component in the Aid
distribution so I'm wondering if
this the swept that is used as part of
the calculation for adequacy Aid if it
were not not revenue from a
tax would
that mean
that it would not be in conflict with
the judges ruling in the Rand case
that's a very good question and it's one
that I I candidly and I know this is a
lawyerly response I don't have an answer
to I mean so the the way that Revenue
has been generated um or at least the
State
education component of educa of of
of um so the non I should say that the
tax the tax revenue has been generated
has been through a a property tax the
State education property tax the
Statewide education property tax and
because it is generate it is that revenu
is generated as a tax it's subject to
the restrictions in the state
constitution um that surround taxes so
part two Article 5 being the principle
one that's focused on that's equal and
proportionate taxation um there's never
been a case that that I'm aware of
that's tested other Revenue sources and
and you know the Constitutional
constraints on those Revenue sources for
funding education and so I I would be
really speculating and and and I I I
don't want to do that and so I know it's
a non-answer to your question but the
reason that that the case so far has
focused just on on taxing and the in the
constraints on taxing power is because
that is the the revenue source that it
has been the primary revenue source for
payments um for for quite a long
time just is it's not really a followup
um I get confused between when the
statement that you made about the where
all the the two bills are um the
difference the Rand case is that was
appealed to the superior court judge and
he
said you know I I'm not going to change
my mind basically and has that what is
the status of that right now has it been
appealed to the Supreme Court I I don't
you know all the terminology absolutely
um so both of the cases conal and Rand
were filed in the superior court so they
were lawsuits filed by plaintiffs in the
Superior Court bringing constitutional
claims um in in conval which had been
pending since 2019 has been to the
Supreme Court once we had a trial um
last May and we got an order in that
case that that was focused on adequacy
and so that's not the Rand case and we
moved to reconsider part of that order
order um and move to stay the order with
the superior court and and the judge
denied that and so now there's a motion
pending at the Supreme Court asking the
Supreme Court while an appeal is pending
of the conval case um to put the trial
Court's order on hold that that's the
payment um of of adequacy amounts in the
increased amount he identified in his
order the Rand case also was filed in
Superior Court and it has two Port parts
of it one part is also an adequacy claim
that has some similarities to the conval
case that hasn't been resolved that that
that claim is still out there the one
that has been resolved is just focused
on on the swept it was kind of litigated
separately within the same case focused
just on the on the tax uh portion of it
and and the procedure there was the
parties agreed that whether the tax was
constitutional was really just a legal
question it didn't require that we go
have a trial where Witnesses got on the
stand and spoke to factual questions
because it was really a question of how
the Constitutional Provisions applied to
the statute as it's written and as it
operates and the judge uh ruled ruled in
a in a written order um that the swept
as it currently operates is not
constitutional and so then we move to
reconsider and stay that decision as
well with the the same judge he he
declined to reconsider his decision or
stay it and so now that is up at the
Supreme Court as well um through a a
coalition of former donor towns so
they're both at the Supreme Court
they're just in slightly different
postures in their separate cases I may
have just made it more confusing I
apologize but
um
okay representative spillsbury
thank you Mr chairman uh thank you for
being here Mr Garland very helpful uh
I'd like to lay out what I think is a
distinction in the status of the two
cases and see if I'm getting this right
so if you could U give me your
feedback in the case of the uh in the
Rand case the question regarding swept
is essentially whether there's a
constitutional flaw in the way that
that's currently distributed
specifically with the excess and if the
judge was uh to stick with this
conclusion and it and it uh uh was
supported by the Supreme Court then
effectively we would have a declaration
of an unconstitutional law and our hand
would be forced as a legislature to do
something to correct
that we may in our judgment want to do
that sooner we may in our judgment want
to wait till the appeal is settled But
ultimately our hand would be forced if
the the uh Superior Court judge's
opinion is sustained is that correct I
think that's a fair way to assess it
what what's happened in past school
funding cases and so I'm talking about
the Claremont decisions in London der is
if the Supreme Court were to ultimately
affirm a decision that the current tax
is unconstitutional it would provide
time for for for this body to consider
ways to address the unconstitutionality
and that's a little wrinkle that exists
right now but I think your assessment is
um May ultimately be forced but is not
necessarily forced yet the trial Court's
decision is subject to to the normal
appeal and and that that's up at the
Supreme Court now so second part in in
contrast to that the conal
case involves uh a much more probative
uh set of testimony and findings on the
part of the superior court judge to
reach a conclusion not just that an
adequate education has to be provided
but what actual amount of funding it
would take to do that and so you said uh
earlier uh in in your
testimony that um a good bit of this is
uniquely in the province of the
legislature and I think it's a major
component of
your um motion for stay
yesterday and I anticipate in your
appeal that that the Superior Court
exceeded its
Authority by getting into a uniquely
legislative
matter and so uh of course we'll hear uh
from the uh supreme court on that as
well but um do you have any
thoughts in terms of protecting the
rationale of your appeal about how far
the legislature should go before the
appeal is settled or should we be
patient
um I'm not comfortable opining or
providing advice specifically in
response to that question so I apologize
I think that that is kind of a
distinction between between your body as
a legislative body the court as a court
system and us as an executive branch
agency what I will say though um and and
hopefully this uh this at least in part
response to your question um is that
there are multiple components of the
conval decision it's it's it's a pretty
nuanced decision it focuses on both a
request for declaratory relief so that's
a a call to the court to say say this
law is unconstitutional um and it also
requests for injunctive relief which is
okay this law is unconstitutional now
the court is going to direct um the the
government in some way whether it be the
legislative branch the the the executive
branch or or someone else um to do
something and so there there is there in
both of those ports
both of those um forms of relief exist
in in the trial Court's order and so the
focus of the motion to stay that we
filed earlier this week was on the
latter the latter uh form of relief the
the injunction that a uh payment to the
in the amount that the that uh Court
identified in its order happen while the
appeals pending um we haven't asked uh I
guess we've asked technically to stay
the Declaration but that declaration
would ultimately be subject to Supreme
Court re viw no matter what and the
Supreme Court would weigh in and in the
end of the day would say yes it's right
or no it's wrong but the thing that
would um have an a more direct impact on
state finances while the appeal is
pending if it's not State as the
injunction component I know that's not a
direct answer to your question but it's
a Nuance in the case that I wanted the
flag um thank you for the followup no
it's a very good answer because quite
frankly I posed the question in part to
learn what you would say and what you
felt you could say but also just food
for thought for my colleagues as we
consider the bills uh but uh I was
particularly
struck uh by the comment in the motion
for stay that was filed yesterday about
the characterization of the injunctive
relief as reading more like a
legislative committee report than a
Judicial
opinion and uh what that was getting at
I think is injunctions are more commonly
used to order that something not occur
but this was much more adventurous in
the sense that the superior court judge
used the injunctive power to compel
action on the part of the legislature
and that's going to be I think the key
question that the Supreme Court will
have to decide and and my my response to
that generally speaking is that uh it's
an important question that arises
frequently in school funding decisions
right it is the Supreme Court has
acknowledged uh and and the trial court
did here too and and I do want I don't
want to overlook that that setting
education policy is largely within the
province of the legislature the question
is um and it's a question that's that
has been litigated for for the past 30
years is what role does the Judiciary in
in addressing the constitutional right
in the Constitution um to to provide an
adequate education have in you know
curtailing what this body does or
directing what this body does it's not
unique to this case it's a question
that's come up throughout this uh this
the the Decades of litigation around
this issue and so I I don't want to
leave um this body with with the
suggestion that that that's not an issue
that that's come up before and it's a
question that ultimately the Supreme
Court will have to weigh in on and has
in the past as well understood thank you
very
much representative
Ames uh one one um aspect of the
litigation that's been ongoing
for 30 years or so
um is
the way in which the state meets its
declared Duty the the duty that was
declared in the CL first Claremont
decision
1993 um
to provide to every child an adequate
educa an opportunity for an adequate
education um
and the the part of the Court's
declaration or or holding in in that
first case was that the state must then
guarantee as part of its Duty guarantee
funding for that adequate education
that's what they said as a quote here um
and they Ed the word
guarantee and it was only in later cases
that uh as I looked at them that were
not directly on the question of how the
state would meet that obligation to
guarantee
funding
um only in the later cases that that
became a state tax or state raised money
that would be the way in which the state
would um comply with its obligation to
guarantee funding and um so all Focus
has been on in in the adequacy
discussions I've been involved in has
been on how the state will raise the
money and um excluded from that
discussion is is local money uh local
property taxes so it's a 100% State
money whether it's from the lottery or
from uh various state taxes including
the Statewide property tax properly
administered um that would meet that
obligation 100% in our sister State our
state next door uh Massachusetts there's
been similar litigation and in that case
they've developed a system where the uh
a part of their Duty it's the same
constitutional phrase that's been
interpreted in both cases are
essentially the same um has been
fulfilled by a
uh
uniform um
contribution by localities to meet part
of that cost of what they don't call it
inadequate education it's a
foundation um foundational education I
guess um and I don't see that issue
raised it seems to me as something that
you could raise the judge is certainly
uh come down very clearly on the side
that the state's duty is to pay 100% of
whatever it defines as adequacy and I
know there's a lot of back and forth
you've argued that he's done it wrong in
terms
of uh
costing adequacy both on both sides of
that um and uh so but but there has been
no suggestion that I can see or argument
um that would push towards hey maybe
this is a joint enter pris that we're
engaged in um both the local school
districts
municipalities on one side and the and
the legislature of the state on the
other side and um and look at it that
way I think there's good arguments that
can be made and um it uh it would
essentially um recognize the fact that
our local school districts are contrib
buting already a significant amount
towards the education of our children
and uh and that that all should be
counted could be counted in a more
comprehensive consideration of the uh of
the issue we have um a bill before us
that uh introduces the concept
representative
fellows um offered it um that we've got
to deal with that uh has the local
contribution Concept in it as one of the
components of the source of funding for
an adequate education and another bill
that's in education which is a product
of the work of the uh uh Commission on
school funding in the 2022 I think um
and that bill too has a local
contribution as a significant component
of the way in which adequacy is to pay
be paid for so I I don't expect you to
say yeah we're going to be arguing that
because you know that you're you're
figuring all this out but I'd really
like to see that and uh if you don't
think that argument should be made I'd
certainly like to hear that response and
uh know that that's where you stand on
it so I don't want to get out over my
skis and and I I really shouldn't um uh
on ter in terms of what we're going to
put into our notice of appeal it's still
not due for a couple of weeks um what I
will say I guess I I have two things I
would say in response to that um the
first is that conal is
um I'm no it is colv Val is the first
case that will go to the Supreme Court
that's focused um on the costing s
portion of of the state's Duty so uh
you're quite right representative Ames
that the first case Claremont one
focused on does the duty exists what is
it um and then over time the Supreme
Court our Supreme Court identified
components to that Duty so um a lot of
cases were focused or a number of cases
at the beginning on what's the
definition and whether the definition
that the legislature adopted was
sufficient a number of other cases have
focused on the taxing mechanism and
that's really what Rand does again as
well um but there isn't a case um it was
it was it existed in the londonairy case
but it wasn't Central to the Court's
resolution okay the way that it's being
costed and funded um by the state is
that constitutional and one of the
questions that's exist that exists in
this case and I think that the trial
court acknowledged it is okay if the
state has a duty to Define an adequate
education and in London da the Supreme
Court has said the state has an
obligation to fund that portion of of
that that that which it defines as a
constitutionally adequate education
where does the the local component come
into that where really is the line drawn
between the state obligation um and and
the local obligation and and what I can
say and this is not this has been um you
know reflected in our public filings in
the trial court is that you know we took
a particular position on that question
kind of where the line is is drawn and
the trial court disagreed with it so it
is an issue that's been raised in the
case and and the idea that localities do
have a role to play in funding education
I I don't think is meaningfully in
dispute in the case it's really what
portion of of of education does the
state have to cover within its
constitutional obligations so beyond
beyond that I'm not really comfortable
getting into the specific things that we
might raise in our notice of appeal but
it's not an issue that that has been
absent from the litigation th
far thank
you representative spillsbury Mr
chairman
um yeah I I want to Echo representative
am's comments I think they are hitting a
very important set of points and
certainly one that this committee is
going to have to deal
with so municipalities are a construct
of the state school districts are a
construct of the state the power to tax
real estate uh for the purposes of
supporting the municipal budget or the
county budget is a construct of the
state it does seem that the distinction
between so-called state level taxes and
local taxes is artificial as a
constitutional matter they're all
essentially the product of decisions
made at the state level furthermore we
tend to view the swept as a SE charge on
top of an existing base of local
property proper tax and the fact that
both the local Ed and the state Ed are
taxing the same item in essentially the
same manner as a mill
rate assessed against assessed
value I think further highlights how
artificial the distinction is so I think
that uh without getting further into
that discussion
now 1563 representative fellow Bill and
um I think it's uh 1686 representative
luno bill which the house referred for
interim study back to
education both essentially proposed to
flip that equation on its head and start
with the idea that there may be a base
contribution whatever that is let's just
say five
Mills and then you build up any
remaining state
aid per decisions that will be made by
the legislature in the
future so it's just very interesting to
think about what does swept look like
and how differently does it look if you
flip it around and you make swept the
base point and then you figure out from
there how do you fill out the Gap um I
don't know whether these play in your
appeal but I think they're absolutely
going to have to play into what this
committee wrestles
withow 1586 not 1686 thank you
representative fellows thank you um I'm
going to talk about the same issue but
from a different perspective um I'm
wondering why in the Rand case the two
sides agreed seem my my interpretation
was that the uh two sides agreed that
the Statewide property tax was uniformed
in rate and equal in valuation am I
correct in that assumption the
pretty much I I that wasn't the let me
put that this way that wasn't the
central focus of of the um of the
dispute in that case the the central
Focus was whether allowing for uh
municipalities to to retain the excess
swept amounts that somehow made the tax
uh disproportionate but follow up follow
but in in
either even in that case the I would
think that the Assumption must be that
they were anyway so I'm just wondering
if if um it was recognized that the
swept rate is not equal across all the
communities um there are reports
published every year by both Dr and uh
the Department of Education that show
the equalized swep rate and it it's
considerably different from one town to
the the next
and um I think that we all understand
that there are definitely good reasons
to want to know what property
values what is the property tax base in
different communities but the process of
trying to equalize those values to put
them all on the same plane is not as
precise science at
all so one of the differences between
the money being raised for Education
through the Statewide property tax from
one Community to the next is that a
characteristic of that is that it's
really
not an equal tax across all of those
communities from my perspective do you
do you understand can you can can you
enlighten me as to why there was no
dispute about that fact in the Rand case
I I would have to go back represent the
fellows it's it's not something that
I've I've thought about recently um and
look into that I know you know when
we're in litigation one of the things
that that happens is you're often
responding to you know the particular
claim that's being brought and so so i'
I'd have to look through what the
plaintiffs and the Rand case
specifically were focused on um my my
recollection um and having read the is
it was really focused on the excess
component not a not an argument that
because of how um the equalization
process works at a local level that it
somehow made
it I
apologize but but my assumption would be
that that wasn't part of the ruling
because the two sides agreed that it
was that equalized and uniformed no so I
I would I would only equ with with the
word agreed um just in terms of how the
litigation process plays out I mean it's
really a a game of to some extent I
shouldn't say a game but of call and
response and so the plain if would would
make a particular argument and you
respond to the arguments that argument
that's being made and so I don't recall
that specific argument being raised in a
way that that it was really addressed in
any of the filings but I'd have to go
back and
check any more questions for Mr Garland
there was an Aly yes
um the conval and the Rand
case are going at this from different
aspects and on from your point of view
I'm not sure that it really matters but
if the Rand case is
decided on before the convo case
on unless we get our representative
Emmer's Amendment all of a sudden
through um we will have a small number
of donor towns that are going to be
screaming about it uh this is a
political fact for the legislature and
it was a political fact in in on 19 1999
and 2001 when we reduced the
$666 60 cents on
swept to
three whatever we reduced it to at that
point it was somewhere around 350 I
think
uh but if for instance representative
emer's on Amendment went through by that
time you would have probably about I
don't know 8 10 times as many towns
screaming very
loudly because their Pro their swept
tax would all of a sudden be close to or
above
uh on
what they are currently paying I
think and
uh that would include my town and would
explain to me why my uh city manager
joined that Coalition when he didn't
have
to but on these these make for this
makes for a really difficult political
environment that small number of towns
managed to get us to reduce the
Statewide property tax essential
eventually to
363 million that would never change with
inflation um
and uh a larger group of towns
that
on that I'm envisaging would probably
make it impossible to pass anything in
the
legislature but um I'm so I'm really I'm
wondering about the process of decision
where they're going to make them and I'm
also on I would like to see that
local
uh uh contribution ideas fleshed out
enough before the court that they could
decide whether they thought that that
was
acceptable it's a different way to do it
that makes it easier on most of the
towns I
think understood but I don't
know and it it is one of the
[Music]
um I'm not sure challenge is the right
word but it it it certainly isn't lost
on me um that the litigation and the
legal questions that arise in litigation
uh affect or influence or or inform or
have some bearing on kind of the larger
policy questions
and I did I grew up in the donor town as
well I can remember going when my U my
father was on the select board as a kid
in Bartlett um going and hearing folks
vocally speak on both sides of that
issue about whether it was a it was a
good policy or not and um and it
certainly isn't laws of me that those
policy considerations which can be
contentious uh kind of permeate what
we're doing litigation um our our
litigation is is focused on um the
Constitutional questions the legal
questions and in that way can sometimes
feel I think uh sterile when you read it
that like it it doesn't take into
consideration you know the the the
bigger policy implications of whatever
the court may decide to do whether it's
uphold the trial Court's decision strike
it down or go a different direction
entirely um but but I think that is just
part of the reality of the litigation so
we're certainly as as I said in response
to representative ases we're we're we're
looking at all of kind of U those
questions as as we're assessing a notice
of appeal
um how they play in is really going to
be a legal question in terms of you know
the the Constitutional interpretation as
it currently stands and and and where uh
the case law fits in with
that it sounds to me like it would be
very likely that um we will not be
expected to act before next
year and so we probably should be
putting forward um
propositions for next year rather than
trying to develop something without
knowing where the Court's
going this
year so as it currently stands in the
litigation um the the trial court has
directed payments be made in conval uh
while the appeal is pending so that the
motion to stay that is at the Supreme
Court it's ultimately up to the Supreme
Court to the side and and the
implications of a decision one way or
the other on that something that I think
all uh you know our office and the
executive branches would have to
consider and and you folks would have to
consider as well um the the Rand case
and is is slightly different because I
embodied in the Court's decision in
there I think is is an understanding
that it will take some time through the
budget process to kind of even if even
if this decision is in place for the the
money to actually be um collected and
and remitted to to Dr and then what
happens to that money is I think a
question that would would be subject to
further legislation but but it's not
something that I guess I I don't want to
speak for for your I can't speak for
your body on what the right choice would
be in light of the litigation I don't
think it's as clearcut that because the
litigation is is is happening right now
there there is nothing that um that the
political branches may be required to do
or or should consider doing while while
the litigation is pending I think there
in my mind they're separate
questions thank you um anybody else any
more questions
okay um thank you very much but I
appreciate if you'd stick around a
little bit longer just in case um
something else comes up but absolutely
thank you it's been very
helpful uh one of the things I want to
do I know we've got the work session
open on hb514 but um while the
Department of Education is here as well
hb1 1655 there was a question yes
yesterday on um the first part of
that
um the the part of the processing um in
bold here in section one add for the
processing of criminal history and
record checks did you have something on
that uh representative Aly and I think I
tracked
down the 6 12 section that is involved
in
this and it is it is dedicated fund
23 but it's um referred in in the
dedicated fund manuals to the wrong
RSA which is about water
uh and it's RS
a21n 9 which is 9 Roman 2 which is Ru
making
S4 is the only place in which education
has been granted the ability to um to
put
fees into the certific this
certification fund which does
exist and would that cover criminal
history it is 213 and it doesn't cover
criminal does not yet um but can that be
can that be done through rule making it
it could be
done through Ru making I am
not
sure whether this is sufficient
RSA to justify it's just uh generic on
the board of education has to develop
standards in order to among many others
things on on set fees for certification
kinds of
activities
and it I don't know if
that's if that is sufficient
authorization or whether you needed
something also in the
standards but I also don't know because
education has divided into something
like 40 different sections which they do
not allow you to search as a body you
have to search each one to see if they
had anything to do with what you're
talking
about so there may be something in
standard somewhere else in
there I don't know if you
know
morning chair and Representative Steve
applebe Department of Education um the
the collection of fees for criminal stre
record checks is also mandated in
189 um there's a several sections in in
that statute as well that speak to this
this was um statutory language passed um
by the legislature several years ago
that tasked the Bureau of credentialing
with conducting criminal history record
checks as part of the credentialing
process and and uh the ability to
collect a fee for that process so do you
do you believe that
um Part B here uh section one I don't
know if you've had a chance to look at
HB
1655 yeah um the the bold face there
were it says and for the processing of
criminal history and record
checks uh based on what you just said do
you believe that
already is handled through RSA 189 if I
was understanding you
correctly yeah well I believe The
Authority is granted okay uh elsewhere
and this this 1655 is more of a
housekeeping Bill the we brought this
forward because um the Bureau of
credentialing collects fees for for
educator licenses and authorizations and
crimin hisry record checks and um it is
a non-aps account of other funds however
it is not continuously
appropriated and we were told by Das
that we needed that language in there so
that those funds would pull forward each
year automatically which would then save
the bureau as well as the department and
ass time in processing requests for
appropriation I see um yeah
representative PL simple question you
brought this forward then this is
something you want this is the
department is asking for this
yes okay representative
Ames okay that it seems to me clear that
we that the first change in this bill
which we've just talked about processing
of criminal history record checks is is
something that you think you need and
who we I see no no reason not to go
along with that understanding um what
about the second part is that uh is
that something that you definitely
need well yes so so part two just um ad
that language by um you'll note on line
line 13 those words continuously
appropriated those were the words we
were trying to get into the statute I
see so that um administrative Services
would treat the account a certain way
that's helpful and I'm sure my colleague
will have a question on that thank you
uh let me just jump to representative
fellows because I know yesterday she
said that she had talked to if I have
these notes correctly the state
treasurer and said um it was better not
to create a new fund as in this section
two so if you want to speak to that yes
thank you Mr chair um I I talked to the
state treasurer and also to I Dena I
think her last name is call she works in
administrative services and she keeps
tracks of of the dedicated funds and um
there already is a fund for
certification and one of the things she
told me is that all agencies
have have to have a review of their
dedicated funds every 5 years and the
Department of Education is coming up for
their review this summer and these and
Technical um issues of which what you
mentioned is one of them but there are
other technical issues in that in two
places in the dedicated fund list that
this particular fund has different names
and when I look at the sheet this is a
the annual report sheet for the um which
is called here teacher certification and
it's something else on the other page um
that the reference to the
RSA is is not the correct reference and
it has partly to do with the fact that
the department was reorganized and not
everything got moved back to the right
place and that both of these issues are
things that can be addressed during that
fiveyear review this summer what happens
is um people you know all multiple
agencies have their funds reviewed and
then any
um uh amendments or that are required
can be part of that big Bill that comes
to the uh this committee and so it can
be dealt with all at once and and you
may have other funds that that need
Clarity and that review process is going
to look at them closely and see what's
necessary so my thought has been that we
keep the top part of um this bill the
part where it puts it in the
um where it just puts puts the um
process for criminal history records
checks and amends that but um not do
anything related to the dedicated funds
at this point and let it go through that
process of review does that sound like a
good idea to
you I I'm I'm F I guess either way that
as I said the purpose was trying to
create efficiency on our end and and
line it up with how the higher education
fee fund runs uh which is not which is
continuously appropriated so um that I
was not aware that they have a review
process
so represent Aly thank you I started
that review
process and I'm still on the committee
and I do all the detail work on the
committee but
on
WE this
this I don't you
you are directing the dedicated fund to
find out what it's about to RSA 21 which
is the a CH separate chapter
in in general
government just about some educ chapter
is just about
education but then you have another book
about
education which is um in on in the 186
area
and first and going
to any RSA
21 is that is Ru making for the
department but there's also rle making
for the Department in in the chapter for
education and the chapter for Education
as I said is divided into something like
40 different sub subsections which are
not
connected and I am really worried that
we're going to have to spend all year
working
on on
your on dedicated funds which there only
seem to be about six of them but there
must be
more
uh that are hidden in in the ru laws
that you've
Rewritten and I hope you can take back
to the department that we've had to do
this with two other departments
that were less complicated than yours
and they took a lot of time so so
represent giving you a warning about
that whatever we decide to do here okay
do you have a just um a thought on that
at this point my other thought on this
is that I don't see
that Ru
making is the same
as legitimizing a fee
and that's essentially what education
has got at this point do they have to
have have something written in the
education law where the certification
stuff is uh that says on that
establishes that there will be fees
which are delineated in this manner I I
believe that statutory already language
exists that that the state board is
charged with setting standards and
collecting fees or it's the commissioner
it's one of
them yeah I did not see that they were
charged with it I just saw that they uh
should write rules for
it yeah it's buried somewhere check
about
that does um okay U represent fellows um
yes I just wanted to um ask you if is it
not true that the Department of
Education knows that it it would be um a
great thing to do to do some
reorganizations of your statutes I
believe you've asked for money for that
before that is not my division um but I
do understand that we have asked on
several occasions For assistance with
that um does anyone have any more
specific questions for Mr applebe on uh
the 1655 that we were talking about I
know that you
know we wanted to get clarification on
this any more
questions thank you Mr applebe if you'd
stick around a little longer as well
appreciate
it um does the sponsor want to talk
about this um at
all
thank you very much Mr chair Daniel
popovic
Miller I just wanted to make a very
quick statement that uh we were talking
a bit earlier about the need to maybe
adjust the legislation a little in the
fact that one of the funds we were
trying to create may already exist and I
would be more than happy to support any
of those changes that are needed as long
as they meet the needs of the department
and I just want to keep it short because
I know you have a long day ahead of you
thank you thank you represent El if I
could just clarify that fund is the one
that
is on amended in
B1 I believe so yes yes so um you're
putting it in the right place the
trouble is just that there's no linkage
going between whatever they think the
law La is that they're using for the
fees and this fully understood and again
any clarification that needs to be made
in the text I'll be happy to support
again if the does can do their job
that's really the intent it's a minor
piece of legislation shouldn't take a
lot of time thank you great thank
you all right now oh did you have a
question oh I just I just wanted to say
if if we want an amendment that keeps
the the uh top part of that bill in in
deletes the part related to establishing
a new fund I'm willing to do
that okay um this afternoon yeah well
it' be good to have it by this afternoon
we could act on it representa
Olie in listening to the discussion the
the question is is that first
part needed now which was the question
representative fellows I think was
trying to get to is it needed now or is
it or could or it could obviously could
be should it be held until
later when you say held until later what
do you mean by that a future Bill
handles that well like interim study so
we have this available so we could uh in
u the fall after this um summer study in
review of the funds we a collective
suggested uh form of legislation could
come out of this
committee representative El me thank you
I think the only
amendment that we
need is to get rid of new subar
paragraph
2 on because sub paragraph on on State
Board of Education section one that is
on all of the language that they put
in on oh no no the uh section two of uh
from 10 from 11 line 11 to line uh
on can come out at this
point because the fund
B1 is being amended to say that it also
does processing of criminal record
checks um
the fund
B1 I think says no no portion of the
funds from these fees shall elapse nor
be used for any other purpose uh nor be
transferred well this is old language
yeah I think we're pretty much I mean
you know we'll get to this specifically
we open the work session on this but
specifically I think we're fairly in
agreement that number two should go um
the question is on paragraph
one yeah as represent ery just said he
believes paragraph one is not needed
either therefore making the whole bill
uh maybe suitable for interim study so
the question more is on one do we need
that language they want to have
processing of criminal history
background checks uh record checks
on B1 is very old language which is not
surprising on
we could
replace
um the the last sentence of
B1 in its entirety um that uh with the
the fund shall be non-lps and
continually appropriated to the state
department of board of education for the
purposes established in this chapter um
and all fees described in sub paragraph
one shall be collected by the board uh
that's modern language that makes more
sense to people these
days okay so I think that that's that's
what we'd need to do represent
fellows something to add yeah so are ask
I'm asking um representative all are are
you saying um take out the second half
of line six in that whole sentence no oh
no I was saying leave leave we need to
leave that in because that's what they
wanted most okay does that need other
than the amendment that's the new um
words on line six any changes beyond
that yes what I was suggesting was to
take out at the end of line 8 to to line
10 which is very old language oh okay uh
and replace it with what's in the bolded
language on starting on page on line 12
the fund shall be non-lps and
continually appropriated and all funds
collected by the board relative to
certifications be deposited in in to the
so that makes sense to me I was just
making sure we didn't get get rid of the
part that says it has to be reasonable
related to the cost of actual activities
that's measurable actually you can you
can leave that in and you can leave in I
think if you want to you can leave in
funds collected from these fees she'll
be expended only for the
purposes but the last part of it is a
very old way of saying non-lps and
continually
appropriated and and non-lps continually
appropriated um means a bit more than
what that old language
did so um did we did we need a fiscal
note on this bill because there is
none or is
it well they're already doing the
processing and they're getting paid for
it in some other way
right so representative
duet maybe I misunder stood but I didn't
hear that it was continually
appropriated no well that that would be
in if we adopted the language that's in
the Bolding no no totally understood and
that's why the question arises as to
whether we should have a fiscal Noe
attached to
this well I think it probably is
continually appropriated at this point
don't you always get in testify it
didn't oh oh no that's that's the
question are these
fees uh do you have any Appropriations
in there other than fees no this is an
other account other it's fee fee funded
account there are no General funds or
federal funds as part of this account
and the issue is they don't they're
non-aps however that appropriation is
not pulled forward automatically every
year and so if something isn't pulled
forward for a particular account and so
for example let's say um our it Hardware
appropriation isn't pulled forward and
and someone's laptop breaks and we need
to purchase a new
laptop the process to have that money
appropriated even though it's there
because it hasn't lapsed is cumbersome
and time
consuming okay so and just to to clear
up if I could we are currently um by
Statute conducting history record checks
and collecting fees and um we have
administrative
rules uh in force for that for that
process so thank you yes that does
clarify
that
okay yeah I think Sally uh
representative fellows you're going to
draw up an
amendment correct and I'll make sure
representative Al me checks it
first okay
I mean
uh representative duet did you have a
concern about continually appropriated
or is that no no I think it was just
explaining
okay all right yes so why don't you you
two coordinate and if we can have that
for this afternoon if possible that
would be
nice right
now act on
this today no we don't have to exec it
today all right we'll see I mean if by
chance during lunch it can be submitted
and when we get it back great if not
we'll take it up
later yeah that's why I said if possible
yes okay um all right so we're back to
to um
hb514
um and as I said we we know we know that
we've got uh 1563 and 1517 all there as
well um are there any more questions
right now that um we want to ask of um
Department of Education or doj's office
um or does anyone have
comments do members have comments about
1514 specifically right now
represent Ames well I I think we're good
for now I think uh we definitely need to
have
another meeting on our swept the swept
issues swept bills MH um presumably next
week I think we've got time to do that
and maybe something will happen in the
courts in the meantime you know we're
going to run out of for that possibility
pretty soon but
yeah yeah right okay um so then let me
close if there's nothing else we'll
close HB 1514 and um we'll most likely
take this up uh probably on Monday the
11th uh in a work session and um point
of order yes you're kind of doing it but
it does seem like as we go through this
list we should have kind of a clear
statement where it's going next if it's
delayed you know we're not going to uh
um do it this afternoon you know just so
it's really clear where we ended for
each of these right that's okay yeah
thank you uh 1514 we will not exec uh
this afternoon and um Mr chairman it is
a it is a bill that needs to be done by
March 21st so there's there's six bills
left uh no six four five yes there we
have six bills um on this sheet that
need to be done by March 21st the other
bills don't need to be out until uh
April 4th and um so keeping that in mind
but we still have we still have time uh
my expectation is I will set a work
session for actually and I need to get
that in today um before one o'clock a
list of uh what we're doing U on next
week and we I'm planning right now not
to have well Tuesday is election day
there won't be any scheduled committee
meetings and the 13th it looks like um
criminal justice has this room on the
13th so um I'm probably only scheduling
the 11th for next week and then the
following week you know leave open right
now make sure you reserve the 18th and
the 19th um and will the 11th have any
execs the 11th will have execs I know
I'm away on the 11th so I'll notify
representative Aly ahead of time
okay I yeah I'm planning on anything
that we have a work session on on the
11th we'll also list as an exec session
in case we're able to move forward and
exec it representative spillsbury thank
you Mr chairman I'm just going to
suggest since you're putting 1514 on for
next Monday that 1517 and 1563 also be
deferred to then we have 15 bills this
morning we're trying to exec this
afternoon unless there's specific
questions of our guests that we want to
ask while they're here and then when we
have that discussion let's have a block
of time because I think it gets thorny
and going to want to take account of
three other bills that aren't
immediately before us just so that the
discussion Embraces six bills on the
subject of swept I'm I'm actually going
to open each one uh separately and but
we may conclude the same thing fairly
quickly so I'm going to close the work
session on
hb514 yes did you have I just wanted to
say that um there's a representative
here from the Department of Education
who can uh talk explain swep and how it
fits into the Ade c a formula so I don't
know if you want to do that today or you
want to is that move that to is Monday
the 11th probably move it to Monday the
11th okay so because I anticipate all
these um were all these fall under the
same category yeah um I just want to see
if people have specific questions on
each one as I open them and close them
so uh 1514 is closed open
1563 um we've kind of been talking about
all these at once does anyone have
anything specific on that
1563 yes so do you want me to just go
through the amendment and how it's
different from the original or hold on
that
also
um given the given the time we probably
should hold it okay to next week okay so
I'll close 1563 and that will also you
know be on schedule for Monday the 11th
um and and I'll schedule these first so
the Department of Justice hopefully and
and Department of Education can come uh
first thing I don't know yet whether
it's going to be 9:30 or actually
probably should start at 9:30 so that we
can get get through as much as possible
um on Monday so we'll all these
education bills those those three uh
1655 I think we're pretty much set with
but so I'll close 156 three
um 1517 U I'll open
1517 U this one
is yeah th this one deals with um excess
money from games of chance but
interestingly yesterday I think we we
concluded that that
bill certainly this is just my opinion
now that Bill may not be necessary
because the highest uh um I'm getting to
my note 5.38 million was the most that
lotteries collected we haven't even
gotten close to the 6.6 million so that
bill uh may be uh moved so this one I do
want to get comments on representative
Ames yeah I I I think this bill is ready
to be EXA exact and uh yeah the I think
the uh what I would be voting for is I
right okay
um we'll do the exact well we have to do
the exact uh this afternoon M Mr
chairman I i' just like to say I
completely concur it doesn't have to
ride with the other SWAT bills it can be
dealt with now and it'll be mooded right
okay good um I'm seeing a lot of
agreement there so I will close the work
session on
um I think are there are there any other
bills so uh that doj or education needs
to be here for I don't want them to have
to Let's
see we talked about
15 1655 does anyone think that we need
Department of Education or doj office
doj's office here for any of the other
bills
Susan are you okay
with
okay we do have the I'm going to butcher
this name but the
testi Banu estate
um but we already talked about that
yesterday yeah I think we're
okay I think we're I think we're
fine okay thank you to the Department of
Education and doj I think we don't have
any further questions today but if you
guys can potentially be available Monday
the 11th starting at 930 we would
greatly appreciate it thank
you okay
um I'll open the uh work session on HB
1193 relative to the establishment of a
child care tax credit program and
recognize representative
pl we heard a lot of testimony on a
different Bill yesterday 1611 relative
to child care Workforce fund and in
hearing that I heard about the dire need
for for uh education for support for
child care uh this this 1193 attacks it
in a different fashion instead of uh a a
work force fund to help uh the Educators
the providers this is a $100,000 credit
towards employers who are not child care
providers to help provide a benefit to
their employees and I think it may be
worthwhile to
consider well it's 100,000 credit up to
10 million uh in
total um representative Aly
yeah I don't think it's going to go very
far if it's just 10 million and if it's
more than 10 million we're in possible
fiscal
trouble
um
it's uh the reason that they put
together that other bill is that it is
trying to get at the
workforce if they can figure figure out
how to get the workforce adequately
compensated there will be more Workforce
and the employers won't have a problem
and it will cost less to do it that way
that's what they were
thinking
on and I'm all for I mean this the child
care area is so
vast that
um it's going to to take as many
economies of this as we can
get but this would
just on at one end of the spectrum it
would only help 10 employers who were
each asking
for for
money I think that's what it ends up
being well if it would actually be 100
employers if it was only one per
employers there's only one per they'd
mostly be the bigger
employers uh well they'd all be the
bigger
employers and that would leave out
everybody
else
and and
frankly well we haven't heard from the
employers
we've only heard from Joe
Sweeney you'd think they would have come
in if
if they thought that this was going to
be
useful with
them in a way that they don't already
have right uh
representa I don't recall uh The
Business Association showing up for uh
this particular piece of
legislation but at the same same time
I'm not sure that that was on
their radar
um I do know that businesses compete
with each other and use the provision of
child care as incentives for
hiring staff
so yeah that's that needs to be taken
into the equation as well right if I
could on one of the top priorities of
the Bia is child care after housing and
um I would be very surprised if they
haven't been following the bills that
are labeled Child
Care representative Southworth I
actually saw your micophone oh great I I
think of the tax credit programs we've
done in some ways as enabling and you
really don't know who wants to take
advantage of it but I think the idea is
good and I think I'm not sure there
would be harm in just seeing what
businesses do with it I don't think it
would anything sudden would happen um
because like anything there are
different strings um but I think it's
worthwhile to consider again that we're
kind of giving it to businesses enabling
because they have other options for tax
credits too and for some this may be the
right one thank you represent
Ames yeah I I think it's a good idea um
but
I I also know that the Dr suggested a
number of
amendments um if you look on the F
fiscal
note yeah it is a fiscal yeah the fiscal
note quick guide is what I have here um
the last five paragraphs essentially are
five
different suggestions or amendments some
of which are definitely
necessary
so you know it's processing issue I
guess I I think it's a good good bill if
everybody else does then we've got to
fix it um I don't think we can do that
before this
afternoon no that's definitely too many
changes
there let me um represent let me just
get some other representative elberger
thank you Mr chairman I would rather see
this money spent in potentially two
other ways one is direct credits to uh
parents of children to help pay for
their child care or credits to employees
who set up child care facilities within
their and this would certainly only work
for larger employers but who set up
child care uh programs within their
facilities which would be a whole lot
more convenient for parents s quite
honestly because they go to work they
drop their children off at this end of
the building and they just walk down the
building to where they're working I I'm
not as fond as this of this model as I
am of either of the other
two represent
Aly
yeah he tacked on microphone please he
tacked on a totally different uh tax
credit which has no financing on a
on on the page
two and he didn't really talk about
it so that also would have to come
out page page two what lines you talking
about on lines one to uh s to eight no I
think it's five oh 52 five
5 um no right no it's one to
prev
okay oh yeah it starts at the end of the
previous page the granite state Paid
Family Leave plan tax credit
M there is no idea of how much money it
would be or anything it's just there
yeah but he seems to have done this
outside of the Child Care
committee representative fellows um yeah
there are a couple of you know maybe the
general concept is fine but there are a
couple like details I I don't like to
see things that say if there's not
enough money we're going to prate it and
when you start because I see that that's
a mechanism that department of education
has used for different kinds of funding
to schools but that's that it works okay
in that situation but when we're talking
about a credit the the company's going
to give out this money or cover this
expense and then claim it as a tax
credit and then after everybody
submitted their tax you know forms then
you're going to find out you they asked
for more than a
hundred that more than $10 million and
and then their tax credit isn't worth
what they thought it was and I just
think that's I don't like to see that
kind of mechanism and the my other
concern is that for at least most of
most of this they have to qualify for
that existing Child Care scholarship
program who's going to monitor that is
somebody going to go and check and make
sure that there it's only going to
people who are qualified so who's going
to do that that's an administrative kind
of
task represent spillsbury
thank you Mr
chairman I'm not prepared to support
this bill for a whole bunch of reasons
and I was about to bring up the $10
million limitation the pro rating the
employer has absolutely no idea what
credit he's going to end up with at the
end of the day I think the mechanism
itself is flawed I have a personal
predisposition that the tax law should
be generally you know neutral uh across
uh you know the breadth of where it's
applied the use of tax credits to me
you've got an uphill um challenge to
justify and persuade me that a tax
credit is a good way of achieving a
social policy so while we may have a
consensus that child care is an issue uh
this vehicle is not necessarily the
right way to go it also it means tests
the individuals it limits the total
amount of the program there's about a
half dozen technical uh changes that the
Dr was going to
suggest and uh it also feels just kind
of peac meal I you know we created a
special committee I would think the
purpose of that special committee is to
create a synthesized comprehensive
here's the set of solutions that are
going to help the state deal with a
genuine problem and for example we have
uh hb6
1611 on the docket today as well which
is an entirely different way of of
dealing with the uh um the child care uh
uh Problem by addressing the employees
of the child care facility so uh I I
just think that this
uh plus what representative Aly said
about there seems to be an epidemic of
proposals for non-aps funds with no
current funding uh designated I think
we've got at least three of them on the
docket today yeah represent roachford
yes thank you Mr chairman um so I put a
lot of work into this over the summer in
this concept and in speaking and I I
I've spoken to a number of my colleagues
here since we had the initial hearing
and I really wanted to see what their
thought was and and and get the feel for
it and I think that you know having gone
through this process understanding there
is a need recognizing there's you know
this is a unique solution I have to
agree with everything my colleague uh uh
at the end of the aisle at the end of
the row here said um there is a special
and I think representative Aly said the
same thing I mean there is a special
committee for child care and perhaps
this is where it should landed to begin
with uh because that's the policy first
and then this is the second this is you
know the the ways and means should be
working on the funding and and and the
money second um so you know my
my position has largely changed on this
to match uh representative spillsbury
and I know representative Aly has said
said a lot of the same things that I'm
thinking representative uh fellows as
well so you at this point I I would be
willing
to you know put this on the back shelf
um for the time being and perhaps maybe
bring it back next year with something
that uh does go through the policy
aspect first then comes to
us thank you um any brother M
representative
Southworth thank you U my opinion
shifted too hearing all of the things I
still like the idea um but I also think
it would be fine for it to go to the
committee uh and hearing all the list of
concerns I just don't think the specific
bill that this is the right time for
it sounds good um all right represent
AES since I spoke on it before I I just
would say that I concur in the
thoughtful comments by the various
people who have spoken just before
me okay there's no other comments uh
we'll close the uh work session on this
bill okay close the work session on
HB
1193 now open the work session on HB
plet yes thank you Mr chair um as a
result of the last hearing we had on
this bill we got a letter from Robert
Scott the uh chair of Commissioner of
Department of Environmental Services he
says when it went through the previous
committee two issues were raised uh one
of which uh was that uh the uh it
applies to all dams as originally
written instead of the ones owned by
Dees uh and so uh and the second issue
was uh Dam removed to prevent
environmental damage it may be helpful
the law for case-by casee exception the
municipal offer requirement well we I
have in front of you
Amendment uh number uh 0960
H uh and that Amendment uh changes the
language so that uh this that it's in
this section state owned Dam means any
Dam owned exclusively by the department
Department of environmental services so
it excludes all of the D dams as a
result so that took care of one of their
concerns the other concern the the in
paragraph three the it says the
procedure in paragraph two shall not
apply if upon receipt of information
reasonably believed to be valid the
commissioner of Environmental Services
believe the DM to be an imminent danger
of failure and a threat to the lives and
property
Downstream we I did have another in a
interim draft that had some additional
language in there but uh the discussion
with my uh House and Senate colleagues
thought it went too far giving the uh
Department of Environmental Services too
much sway but we do have this language
in here about imminent danger so they
don't have to offer if it's collapse so
we think we've taken care of the the
concerns of the uh Department of
Environmental Services and it's ready to
go forward before the the policy has
already been decided that remind people
of that so what we're looking for from
this committee is just simply
establishing the fund and putting a
dollar in it and that way um through the
but normal budget process starting next
year the dees can request funds to be
put into that fund and would go to the
various Finance committees to act
on thank you representa
lle thank you Mr chair thanks for taking
my question um thank you for the
amendment I think it does address a lot
of the issues uh one question I have is
just to confirm
that if the department does is able to
get money put into this fund it would be
money that would indebt the
municipalities it wouldn't be State
funding for a state responsibility to
take care of the the dams it would be
money to loan
municipalities who would who want to
take over the dam exactly right it would
be State money only to fund uh this line
item uh as a a potential loan to
municipalities which would be paid back
with
interest as an alternative to bonding um
and and uh so it could make money uh in
the process of of because it' have to
pay back with interest uh and so it
would have to have sufficient funds in
there at least the the immediate problem
is gos down uh with with the but but
there's 273 dams throughout the state
that they own and and so so it will
affect many other municipalities besides
gwn
eventually and I have a followup to that
thank you
um so I guess my hope would be that if
the dees needs
funding to take care of the dams that
fall under their purview that they are
indeed responsible for that they would
request
funding not to go not only funding to go
into this loan program but money from
the state to live up to the state's
responsibility to take care of the dams
that fall under their purview so I hope
that that the department would make that
request um if if funds are needed thank
you absolutely right but the what we're
talking about is uh dams that uh no
longer have a commercial
uh Hydro power therefore they lose the
ability uh to have a license from Fork
I'm not swearing Federal Energy
Regulatory Commission uh uh to maintain
that Dam so the dam would eventually
have to be shut down unless there's a
process in place to put fish ladders in
uh and that may be beyond the state
purview to do but the municipality might
want to tackle that right now they have
a grant for request for $2 million to
the feds to to put fish ladds uh fish
passages I shouldn't say ladds this
passages around Kelly Falls in
Manchester and then truck to Greg Falls
in in uh North uh excuse me uh west of
uh that that Dam so that those dams
would be able to have uh commercially
viable hydro and keep their Federal
licenses the one that's in question
right now is Hadley Falls in downtown
gson which is probably a goner but we
maybe want to replace it with some sort
of Coffer Dam that feds wouldn't
consider a Dam to keep the economic
activity going that's something that the
state would not
do representative
Elber thank you um I want to try to
clarify a couple of things because at
this point based on the assumptions I
have I'm not fond of this bill so I want
to find out if my assumptions are
accurate
uh the um
representative PL you talked about
they're not commercial they're they're
not uh generating hydroelectric power is
that right um there is a Hydro power
facility at Greg Falls there's one
currently at Kelly Falls but the but the
own the generator at Kelly fall says we
can't afford these fish passages so
we're going to submit to Federal Energy
Regulatory Commission to uh give up our
license which would require removal of
the dam uh so state is thees is stepping
in with a grant request to put the fist
passages in and with the fist passages
they'll be negotiating with somebody to
continue prod providing power there but
it's not it's not possible for a
commercial entity to do that it's just
way too
expensive my concerns are if if I may
follow up my concerns are
that with the state as the owner manager
of the dams they are looking beyond the
immediate impact of a specific Dam
they're looking at what happens
Downstream from the dam and it's
unlikely for that broader thinking
broader impact thinking to be taking
place if each Community is responsible
for its Dam or its several dams and I am
concerned about the fact that well I'm
I'm in town a and I I want to deal with
my dam this way and I haven't talked to
town B which is just Downstream and it's
going to have a serious impact but
that's not my problem if I'm only taking
care of my dam I understand first of all
that's a policy issue that I think has
already been decided but uh I I'm sorry
I
I'll let you finish yeah but the policy
issue that was taken up in the first
committee um in in my particular case
it's it's Hadley Falls downtown gos down
which is pretty small and Upstream from
Upstream from that there isn't any to to
for quite a distance uh there may be a
small one in New Boston but it's it's
it's uh uh the I
guess our task is to establish a dollar
fund that's it I if I may just one one
followup I see this as a financial issue
because if in my decision making as town
a I take action that causes Financial
harm to town B which is Downstream
that's a fiscal impact and I don't think
that we can dismiss that potential
fiscal impact thank you I think Dees
would take that into account involve
Town
B question Mr chair
representative
Al you you said all right thank
representative thank you Mr chair
representative PL you said this is a not
a policy
question uh has there been any
change on your amendment to what was the
original bill in wording or in cuz I
can't match up some of the lines here
with the original bill
well it in section one this section
state owned Dam means any Dam own
exclusively by the department that
wasn't in the original Bill
okay thank you is there any
other line 21 to
23 that's the that's the essence of it
so it's it's instead of all state dams
it's dams owned by the Department of
Environmental Services there there is
another
change on page
two lines four and
five so after saying any municipally
owned Dam this now adds or Dam owned by
other interested parties who are capable
of assessing local property taxes or
issuing
debt that came out of the previous
committee's work actually uh so the dees
was saying if the uh town or Min City
may not want to do it but but there may
be a a a uh Village District formed uh
which which which could do this sort of
thing which might be Beyond a town or
city uh so so so but that that that that
is you're correct that's an additional
change but they have to have capab that
came from the M Municipal Association
they would have to have taxing Authority
to be able to do
that represent what would be an interest
oh I'm Sor I'm sorry so an interest
party would be what a village District
what else could it be it has to have
taxing authorities so would have to be a
village District so let's not say or
other interested parties well that that
is it it's got they've got to have
ability to raise to to impose fees on
their if if if it could I suppose be a a
a it's a Property Owners Association
that has has has the ability to T tax
their residents with uh uh to to do
that are there any represent yes that
that are allowed to tax their residents
uh not with use not with the word tax no
I I live I live in a co-op for over 55
community and I have $500 a month rent
and I have to pay that or I get evicted
yeah so that it's it don't call it a tax
same Home Owners Association same thing
but it's not a
tax
so I my question is how we can fit into
this
something that either
says that it only involves
dams that
have uh
that have no significant impact on the
waterways below
them below below the the town in which
it is or that there is
mandatorily uh that the towns that would
all be
affected join together in this
in this project below but but you mean
below do you mean Upstream Downstream
Downstream I don't know how a damn there
actually there are sometimes effects
Upstream uh when you impound water and
then you you open it up all of a sudden
it's they're extreme in Lebanon area um
but the on what we're talking about is
Downstream if
they if the dam collapses or if uh the
dam on dams the water to a larger extent
so you've got a nicer Lake but down
below you've you've got a creek uh where
you used to have a
river on and you have a dam there that
can't
operate H with Hydro because it's lost
most of its water
um this this is a situation that we get
between the US and Mexico on the border
we've stolen most of Mexico's
water for the west of Mexico and but it
was because they weren't thinking about
these things in those
days let me just interject here I mean
the whole idea of this could get
extremely complex so I the question I
have right now is how does does it work
now if a state if the state decides to
remove a dam they remove the dam they
remove the dam they are responsible for
any liability Downstream they they are
responsible for removing the dam
safely uh and uh that's it uh and uh
what happens Downstream happens
Downstream their responsibility is to
remove the dam that could be a potential
Hazard um and U this does not
contemplate building bigger dams or
anything like that with the concern that
raised by representative Aly comes into
play that's one of the things that I
brought up but there are a lot of
different things that can go
on well the reason for my question
representative PL was I if at the end of
the day if the
state is I don't know I guess um gives
its approval to the to the plan then the
state would still be the one liable if
something right I think I think the
issue is towns towns could could get
destroyed by being liable for something
going wrong I think that's part of the
issue Town's can get destroyed by having
the damn fail and the concern with
the is that uh dams the Hadley Falls uh
is is a hazard right now U uh because
it's not it's not put into the Bedrock
well enough it was done a long time ago
so it will eventually fail so that they
do have to remove it and it's it to me
it's a gone a done deal uh the question
is can we put some sort of Coffer Dam
smaller in so we still have the economic
ability uh uh to to to economic benefit
but without without Federal Energy
Regulatory condition calling at a dam uh
so I'm not sure what all the concerns
are about bigger dams or anything like
that that's not going to happen
representative Lee please thank you Mr
chair um I agree with what you bring up
Mr chair this is my main concern is is
passing on this kind of liability to a
city um and I would like to add to that
idea my understanding that the state has
already entered into this kind of
understanding with cities I don't think
the state is barred from entering into
this kind of agreement with cities so
I'm not
sure that we need this piece of leg
ation so that the state can enter into
such an agreement with a city um so to
me it seems like we don't need it to
solve the problem that gtown is facing
for example um and I think it raises a
lot of very big concerns
so thank you Mr chair representative
spillsbury
I concur with that um but Shifting the
conversation to the fiscal side what
we're doing here is we're creating a
hollow construct putting $1 into it and
then it just goes onto the Shelf until a
future legislature decides to fund it it
doesn't even activate unless it's got a
minimum of 2.5 million I heard estimates
during the hearing that it might take 40
to 50 million to be a um you know a
dynamic program so I uh without opining
on the policy issue I think from a
fiscal standpoint there's no real point
in advancing this bill at this
time respond yes without the without the
fund uh the uh I guess the purpose of
the fund is so that the dees can ask for
money uh and go through the budget
process next year there's a fund to put
it that's all and so you're you're right
that the Dollar by itself isn't doing
anything but we will enable the de to
request funds to be put into it through
the normal budget process in future
years and the rest of that was all
policy issues was brought
up be on the finance representative Aly
followed
by uh ores and then fellows but we know
that the
de for at least 20 years now has had
insufficient funds to pay for the dams
that they consider highest
priority and so you're going to be
asking them to ask for both things at
the same
time and get a little of each
maybe representative ORS I'm sorry could
I ask you to repeat that I couldn't hear
you yeah oh sorry um well I'm thinking
of the Pittsburgh Dam which is at the
top of the Connecticut and which is on
the Connecticut River and Lebanon is
halfway down and um they had to delay
for more than 10 years the inspection
that they know knew they needed to do
and repairs they needed to do so that it
wouldn't
break and this is 20 years
ago and I was
informed that I shouldn't worry because
it the surge if it broke wouldn't get to
Lebanon but there are a number of towns
in
between so um they've been in the and we
had to work with them early on because
the governor didn't want to spend the
money on dams and we were trying to
figure out a way to get enough money so
they could sort of keep up with their
scheduling
and this is still going
on yes so um I absolutely agree with you
I don't understand why we're taking what
in my mind seems to be a state issue and
trying to pass it off to the town for
one thing another thing is I discussed
this with my wife she's environmental
scientist she said there's a lot more
going on with the dam especially a dam
like Pittsburgh that's been there for
many decade she said there's there's
this buildup behind the dam that if they
were to just take it out and Let It Roar
there's a lot more going to happen then
people realize it will wipe out the
fishing industry and so so forth so why
are we going to pass this off to the
towns I mean this sounds like something
maybe the governor asked for emergency
funds from Washington to help work this
problem this this is not a town problem
this problem is much bigger than
towns represent fellows um yeah I want
to just kind of wrap together some of
the things I've heard here so one
concern I have is using money for a
non-urgent situation when the dees has
told us that uh
273 state owned dams need 4
$414 million in repair and that the
category that's High Hazard will cost
$300 million to repair how we can think
of putting any money into a fund for
municipalities to use to um fix a dam
that doesn't fit into that category
that's um really concerning and the
other thing is I still don't have any
Clarity on what can happen now with the
dam because somebody else mentioned this
but I remember somebody saying that the
dees can sell a dam to a or transfer a
dam to a municipality already so if
that's in I just I would like to know is
that
correct represent Aly yeah uh that may
have been what I said and they have done
that in the in the case of Lebanon but
it was one of the dams that does not
affect other
municipalities it right
across Route 10 it was going to going to
wipe out piece of rout 10 if it went but
on it was right across Route 10 from the
hydroelectric
Dam it was an old old dam for uh water
for the boilers for the
trains is there a statute that says that
they can do that I'm sorry I didn't ask
for I don't know if there's a statute
but they offered it to us they said
we're either going to take it out which
is fairly easy with a small one on or uh
you take it over and we'll teach you how
to to shore up the
dam which is what we
did because it was a major Recreation
asset for
Lebanon all right um yes represent
spilsbury I think we're getting to the
point very quickly because I don't think
we want to debate this now but I it
seems to me that I could conceive a bill
being drafted that would deal
specifically with the GS toown problem
and a funding mechanism tied to it and
that would be an interesting Bill to see
next
term thank you I think we've uh I think
we pretty well exhausted this for now um
unless someone has some very compelling
thing to say just sorry
so we are going toct that one this
afternoon I feel we probably will yeah
so I'm just trying to always you know
have that at the end okay yeah you know
what I mean yeah I mean some of the
while I I can make an statement about
that keep in mind that the two caucuses
May conclude something else and then we
change our path but right now it feels
like we'll be executing it okay I'm
going to close the work session on uh HB
1429 we now open the work session on hb4
1970 establishing a study committee on
the feasibility and impact of lowi
income housing credit excuse me Mr chair
yeah um I have an amendment for 1470 may
I pass it out
sure
oh
thanks do you want two copies yeah I'm
pissed
may I speak to my Amendment yeah
yes there there weren't huge changes to
this so I'd just like to draw your
attention to the changes we've made um
on line
nine
um it also refers to instead of just
low-income housing we added and
Workforce housing um and that same
change is reflected at line
20 um at line
13 um we clarified that three members of
the house would be um appointed by the
speaker and three members by the
minority
leader and um at line
19 I think this is reflected above and I
missed it um the duties of the committee
uh they would study the impact of a tax
credit and other incentives we added and
I think that um Committee Member Aly may
remember other changes that were made
but I think that's
it
I see everybody diligently looking at it
so I
will
wait yeah
any initial
comments yes I'm good with the changes I
I would support this
Bill yes I would ask the question is
anyone familiar with whether we have had
committees studying this or whether we
have a committee in prog in process
right now or not can I respond I know
that on Friday um this coming Friday
there are two meetings um about the
topic of housing okay one being by the
special
committee not it's not a study committee
of this particular issue like this bill
recommends but there are are going to be
I believe two different meetings on
Friday on the issue of housing
broadly represent spillsbury
so what's the advantage of creating a
study committee when the speaker already
created a special committee specifically
to focus on this
issue that was my question so there is a
committee already focused on
this
can't hear the conversation
sorry I'm sorry I thought my mic was on
I say the special committee um broadly
focuses on housing
needs you saying there is a special
committee already focusing on this may I
respond yes so this committee is um
looking at tax credits and other
incentives to increase the availability
of low-income housing which I think is a
low-income housing and Workforce housing
which I think is more specific um I know
that the meetings on Friday I see that
representative Ames is is looking I
think that they're all speaking to bills
that are currently um being considered
so I think there it might be a public
hearing about bills it might be a work
session but this committee is
specifically looking at increasing the
Ava availability of low-income housing
and Workforce housing which I think is
is a more specific charge than the
overall housing you know ex housing
market um that currently exists I
believe representative fellow did you um
okay representative Ames I just uh I I
was looking at that yes um I believe the
special committee on housing is a
committee to which bills that relate to
the subject matter of that H housing
committee are assigned for review and
action like our our committee is but
it's got a this focus on housing uh so
it's it's reviewing bills I don't think
it's studying an issue like the issue
that's proposed in this bill uh for a a
focused review and uh
report two different things I
think representative
Aly yes um it seems to to be
concentrating on
zoning and other
judicial uh on Municipal and judicial
difficulties with that stop housing in
general more than than this specific
issue which is the lower income
workers okay um
which they may get to if they keep doing
for a couple of
terms may I add in sure um it's now
coming back to me that I a lot of the
ongoing conversation that I'm aware of
um in my own City and and at the state
level is about zoning and how we can fix
zoning so that we can build more housing
and and I think that this one is not
particularly um focused on zoning um but
really on low-income and Workforce
housing which I think can be impacted by
zoning um um decisions but certainly is
is broader and really deals with kind of
uh the broader Workforce issue that
we're facing in New Hampshire
thanks representative Ames did you have
a further
comment I don't think I I I was just
looking up what's in excuse me what
what's in our
um on the the general Court's website
and New Hampshire housing standing
committees the special committee on
housing is identified and its membership
is identified but there's not
any I was pursuant to house R 31 so you
bear with
me I'll go to
that does anybody else have something
representative spillsbury it was my
understanding that that special
committee was given a charge to look
comprehensively at means of dealing with
Workforce housing this bill is this
amendment is now proposing to broaden
the Horizon of this study committee to
include Workforce housing and makes that
overlap even more
direct yeah I don't think
oh I we have two definitions of
Workforce in people's minds on
unfortunately we have the general
Workforce and we have the workforce
housing definition that we put in about
15 years ago on that uh
codified a Judicial decision
on and that definition is for usually
most of it is
60% of the median income can
afford this item so it's a lot of
workers but they are the workers that
have the hardest time being able to stay
in New
Hampshire which is why we don't have
enough people doing the wells we don't
have enough people doing the septic
systems we don't have enough people
doing the electricity uh we don't have
enough people on
Roofing
in this state and we that's it's a major
housing issue of its own as well as
being an issue
for enough Baristas
enough girls in dance halls
whatever I mean it seems to me that from
my perspective one of the one of the
major things here is is there is there
overlap how much overlap and is it
covered for now Now by what we have
going representative Ames I'd like to
comment on that we did have testimony
from Ben
Frost um who the New Hampshire what's
the uh
you Housing Finance Authority and uh I I
know him from other appearances before
this committee over the years he's one
of the most knowledgeable people I think
in in uh this field and an excellent uh
proponent of um good housing policy and
he came before us to say that yeah this
uh this was needed that uh essentially
saying there's not not another Endeavor
that's overlapping this um and was
recommending that we go forward with it
I take that recommendation as
substantial and persuasive to
me representative fellows um yes on
pretty much the same line I agree when
when we have bills people from the state
departments and the Finance Authority
they they come in here and they almost
always say I don't have an opinion you
know I'm not supporting or or being
opposed to a particular bill I think
when you have a study com commission or
committee that that's an opportunity for
them to tell you what they really think
so I would like to see this bill pass
okay um seeing no more hands we'll close
the work session on hp1
1470 now opening the uh work session on
HP 1613 establishing a trust fund for
money uh from Soil and
Water environmental
contamination
representative
Amy thank you we have a slight problem
we've lost representative
news that is we can't find
him and um we we don't know whether he
intended to
amend uh his bill
further after reading the commissioner's
letter or whether he felt that he'd
already covered
it was he asked for an
amendment actually we do have an
amendment from him yeah we
do um and it's from the middle of
February and the commissioner's letter
is from the end of February oh no end of
January but I think he just got it when
he arrived here to
speak
I say we can't find him and that's we've
only been trying for a
day and and um and the question is what
whether there's a
further whether because of the
commissioner's letter there were some
other things that he would have wanted
to put into the
amendment or take out of the
amendment
and I don't know if we could delay this
one
until I guess it would have to be the
week after next because next week we're
just doing property
tax um no this
is no um no not necessarily what do you
mean just property tax no we're doing um
we're not just doing the swept bills no
so we could try to to get we could get a
hold of them by then I
hope
yeah how do how do people feel about
this in general um say later
list put it on the later list so at
least he can have a chance if he does
have
something all right then uh let's let's
close the work session on this um at
this point
1613 open the work session on hb1 1410
relative to certain professional
licenses
represent Aly if you look at the 229
fiscal note they have essentially said
that that what they the only real loss
they're likely to get is going to be
95,000
in the next bium which they were
thinking of sticking into their
budget right which is kind of um virtual
or whatever based on yesterday's
testimony the the fiscal impact was uh
about on10th of what had originally been
stated any other comments on this uh on
this bill I never got that Ro recent
fiscal
note um okay it's online
and yeah I don't have it either
oh sorry 95 from 9 I take that back I
gave him mine I'll take the here's
here's another
one anybody else needs
one that's that's my collection of stuff
thank you
I'm going to throw all right any other
represent he did change the bill was
changed just to deal with medical
technicians on the
financial yeah decrease that the state
would
face
right it was amended before it came to
our committee yeah
okay are we all set on
this okay we'll close the uh work
session on hp1
1410 I'll open the work session on hb1
1655 and I'll REM uh okay actually we we
talked about
1655 and um it looks like barring the
ability to get an amendment today which
sounds challenging uh we would take that
up on Monday
um okay close the work session on
1655 open the work session on 1198
relative to liquor stores and that was
the
Christmas thanksgiv Easter um openings
and um the
policy was approved obviously it's a
second committee Bill however we did
have some question yesterday about um
does this increase revenue does it not
increase Revenue um
thoughts representative PL the answer to
my answer is I don't know uh but uh yeah
but but New Hampshire Liquor Commission
doesn't know but but uh but they have
find that maybe won't be any increase in
Revenue but uh
if I if this bill passes I think they'
try in couple of major stores to see
what kind of revenues they did get and
what and what what revenues uh decreased
in the days leading up to it and see if
there's a net benefit it's enabling leg
enabling legislation only but they have
the choice to open or not open right
representative
alberger thank you Mr chairman I I agree
with representative F flet this is
simply a way for the Liquor Commission
to figure figure out do we make more
money or not and given that I think it's
fine thank you representative Amy and I
agree but I think that the Liquor
Commission feels that they do know that
it doesn't that it's going to would lose
them money and they probably won't do it
but they'll have the option for the
future if they want to do it
later thank you I'm going to close the
work session on oh one more yeah I I
believe I heard two comments yesterday
where there may have been just a little
bit of a confusion so um to
clarify if it's
helpful so the this bill removes a
restriction as to only three holidays
Easter Thanksgiving or Christmas what
that leaves is the first part of the
sentence and so it does apply to all
legal
holidays in other right so by removing
the Restriction Liquor Commission would
have discretion on Sundays and any legal
holiday and another comment was made
about how how much overtime is required
if it's a holiday versus if it's a
Sunday but the the last sentence in uh
8910 specifically pegs it at one and a
half times and by
saying um on such days that mean one and
a half times is the rule both for
Sundays and any
holiday represent fellows so one of the
questions I had about this yesterday had
to do with that part about the one and a
half time pay because I you know I don't
know for sure I can't tell you where
it's written but it seems to me that
it's a common practice that one and a
half time times pay is for over 40 hours
but when um there's a holiday when the
rest of the people when in an
organization would normally have off and
people work overtime or on a holiday
that their rate may be higher than one
and a half times and that that is
controlled by usually by um the
contract the LA that the labor union has
um NE negotiated I'm particularly I'm
thinking of the state hospital seems to
me that's where I heard it that context
that when they work um on a holiday in
at the state hospital it's more than a
time and a half so if we put in statute
paid at time and a half well this is for
liquor but I I don't know I don't know
what the contracts currently call for so
that's just a
concern represent Bolton thank you Mr
chair so in representative Horgan
testimony he did say in paragraph 4 that
the commission is free to keep the
stores closed instead and then full-time
employees would be guaranteed at least
one and a half times the regular pay and
all the work rules would still apply so
I think that might be an error that his
testimony doesn't match how the bill is
actually written and I I agree with u
representative fellows that it might be
contrary to contractual
agreements
but
okay represented
Ames microphone way microphone
please this this
uh bill as representa spilsbury has has
pointed out leaves in place it removes a
a a
uh a restriction on three days but
leaves in place
all the other language which um has been
in place for a long time and uh so the
Restriction the statutory restriction of
one and a half times has been there and
um whatever the rules may be for
additional overtime and how interplay
between this statutory provision and
perhaps a collective bargaining
agreement I don't know but uh no there's
no change here we're just uh allowing
this uh liquor stores to operate on
these other three
days right we're assuming that language
was already there and has been
instituted
yeah represent
Southworth H thank you it seems like it
would be easy to just find out from The
Liquor Commission what they pay on
holidays again I think it is 1 and a
half% um but people question if there's
a discrepancy it's easy to ask them you
know they have the contract they've been
paying people all year um and it may be
that the match is fine but we don't know
so we can just ask them
right well to represent am point this is
this was already in
the so really perhaps you just know
other agencies but if this is the fiscal
note if that is absolutely correct we
really don't have to worry about it it's
really not up to
us changing that part of the bill is not
before
us
okay anything else on
that saying none close the work session
on HB
1198 now open the work session on hb1
3 um and I'll remind everyone that
this has no fiscal note and probably
could have been waved and not come to
our committee so um technically speaking
it would it would just be an
OTP um
unless I don't see any one okay all
right we'll close the work session on
1293 HB 1303 I'll open that one
relative to the state of
testi B I know I'm not saying that right
yes representative PL my guess would
be uh Toy
Banu so anyway my only question I I have
no problem but only question is how much
was the money involved it's 150,000
comes to mind but yeah something
something in that range
something 131
yeah
any comments I think we can pretty much
put this one to rest
okay end of work
session uh open the work session on
1565 relative the definition of
potentially hazardous
food uh I think that one is pretty
straightforward as well you know when I
object to agriculture calling pickles
hasd all right you all have to take that
up with
them
any comments on that
one seeing none I'll close work
session 15
16 H I'll open the work session HB
1709 uh that again falls into the same
category there's no longer fiscal note
that
um that should have been waved as well
so we can move on from that one
seeing no dissension I'll close the work
session on
1709 all right last but not least hb1
1611 I'll open the work session on that
Rel to establishing a child care
Workforce
fund
representative
Aly yes um I have had conversation with
Mary Jane Walmer who is one of the uh
people involved in the child care uh
special committee as well as
um representative MC Williams who wasn't
able to come on
and the
reason they've put this together in a
way that will fit what the Senate
promised would be another
appropriation next year and that would
take it out of the hands of
HHS
on partly because they think it will be
more
efficient as as a independent
um what they they call a designated
entity that would do it uh in the same
sort of way that um all of
those those uh
voucher School vouchers have been put
into the hands of an
individual but with more um
transparency
and that it is set up so that that
entity can will be making grants to
child care employ
lawyers who can do any of a number of
things that sug say that they are going
to want to do any of a number of things
that they think will be most helpful to
them for expanding the
workforce
um which is why there's this whole list
of
them
and I must admit when I was was reading
this I had misunderstood a whole lot of
it because I don't do child
care so I just wanted
to oh and and one other
qualific uh thing that I learned from
her page two on they've got the child
care programs operating in New Hampshire
with an Active Child Care license or
license exempt and enrolled in the
Department of Health and Human Services
child care scholarship program um and
they go as far as summer camp programs
but uh the B turns out to be the Boys
and Girls
Club on a number a fairly large number
apparently of years ago went to the
legislature and managed to get EX itself
Exempted from
licensing and there are a few others
that are included in that that
category and
so they would also be able to
apply but so so what do we do with this
bill well this is from the special
committee uh even though they they
started out at the beginning to say it
says Health and Human Services and
elderly Affairs but it was sent to the
special committee on Child Care um this
see I think is their main work product
this
year so I I am Child Care is the second
highest priority of the Bia after
housing to do something about and I
would
hate not to do something about it and
they do seem to have have their heads
together about what is going to happen
with
it
yes representative duet okay um just
very briefly and and bia's been referred
to a couple times but um they you know I
would I would hope we we were talking
about I think it was 1193 where we
didn't get any testimony from the Bia we
didn't get any from them yesterday also
about six uh
1611 my reservation with this is and I I
we all can acknowledge we have huge
issues with child
care
but for me setting up a a blank check
approach with the testimony we heard
from I'm not sure as to who's doing the
grant writing for the state but they got
a grant for $15 million I I wasn't
convinced
that the the benefit of this quite
frankly personally myself unless
somebody can can convince me other
otherwise what this does is sets up
another dedicated
fund
and um I'm just not entirely comfortable
with it as to what I heard yes yesterday
testified in front of us could I correct
that wasn't a $15 million grant that was
the state senate putting into the budget
$15 million for child care okay I stand
corrected I in order to uh start the
work and they they sent it to
HHS to do something the first year so
that they'd get started and then on they
also put in apparently into the finance
committee Budget on which is so huge I
wouldn't blame anybody on the finance
committee if they didn't notice it but
they put in at the same time something
that said that we intend this to be
ongoing that every term they were going
to do that now they can't tell the next
Senate what to do anymore than we can
tell the next house what to do but that
was they put their intention there in
the
budget I'm just if I may I'm just being
transparent it was an appropriation set
setting up a a dedicated fund is
something I'm very timid about so I'm
just being very transparent right
now or at least I'm trying
to
right thank you Mr chair um a couple
things appear a little bit different to
me about this bill than some of the
other ones we've discussed one is that
$50 million was appropriated by the
state to to this ends this year so
whereas some of the other things we've
talked about we we haven't seen that and
it's been acknowledged by you know
everyone in the state both sides of the
aisle that this is a really important
issue this is product of a special
committee who put a lot of work and
thought into it and we had a lot of
testimony from our citizens in support
of this bill the other reason I think we
should support it is that we have DHHS
funnels Federal money to support
lowincome families to be able to get
their kids in daycare so that they can
go to work and it seems like this
approach supports the businesses that
are running daycares and you know I know
some folks who run daycares and they
need support So it seems like it it
provides a balance to what we already um
are doing to make this continue to be a
viable business uh in our state so it it
does seem a little bit different to me
and I think the bill is quite good while
not perfect but
um I think that the Senate is working on
the same thing I understand and so maybe
that could be
perfected um later on but I don't want
to get in the way of this bill passing
especially because it has no impact as
it's written right
now
representative Ames followed by
Elberta yeah I I Echo the comments that
we just made and um and I don't think
it's been said but this is a a
bipartisan Bill strong support from both
sides of the aisle and that's nice when
that happens um and um the underlying
issue we all know is uh urgent and uh
makes uh addressing it and making a dent
in uh the problems people have because
of the absence of affordable child care
is
um import will will help the state in a
big way and so um I I hope that we can
go forward with this we we didn't have
uh any opposition that I can recall
um other than some questions that were
asked by members here appropriate
questions um I think we're getting
beyond that we should just go forward
with it as good it's a it's a uh a start
it's not it's not going to solve all the
problems in the world but it's a start
and I think we
should enable it representative
elberger thank you Mr chair this bill
also helps a different group of
employers and those are the employers
who can't find people to fill their jobs
because they're these potential
employees can't get child care so if you
look at the whole piece of it if we have
the providers who have been telling us
they have empty rooms because they can't
pay their staff they'll be able to hire
more people and those parents can then
fill some of the jobs that are going
wanting now so I think this uh is a
winwin for a whole whole lot of
groups um representative uh fores
followed by spilsbury thank you so yeah
my only concern I mean I sympathize with
what I heard the other day my concern is
if we start funding this group what
what's the next group I don't know
that's my concern so I I man it sounds
like such a tough situation but I don't
know that government involvement is the
answer represent spilsbury thank you Mr
chairman we we heard yesterday that uh a
prime difficulty with hiring and uh
retaining daycare workers is pay that
they're competing unsuccessfully with
Walmart and McDonald's that they would
need another $5 an hour I mean these are
really deep problems in terms of the way
the competitive Marketplace for for
Labor uh operates but what does this
bill propose to
do it's using the mechanism of another
one of these empty vessels a of an
unfunded fund that's going to be again
like so many non-aps and continually
appropriated so it doesn't get by anal
review in the Appropriations process and
then it it asks the designated
entity to look at the specific uh uses
listed in lines 19
through3 with the purpose of Staff
retention and Recruitment and and I'm
looking at this specific list and I'm it
it's not clear to
me why some of these background checks
uh professional cost
CPR uh Health dental uh Whole Life
vision insurance paid time off
equivalent I don't see
how spending uh grant money on any of
those things really addresses the
fundamental flaw in the employment um
competitive employment Market
and and I'm not
sure at least it's to some of them I'm
asking is this really going to help to
recruit and retain daycare workers or is
it in some cases going to prepare day
workers to go take flight and go
somewhere else with the new newly
acquired skills so I I would leave it at
that I'm just very very troubled at how
completely open-ended it is there's no
real criteria for what the value the
impact is and how one one qualifies it's
one of the most wide openen programs
I've seen come across our
desk and finally I just don't see any
limiting criteria here there's nothing
that says you know up to $1,000 per
individual per year uh or or anything
else so uh you know let's just say that
we passed this and next year let's just
say the legislature puts $15 million
into this fund and now what exactly are
we expecting this designated entity to
go do and how did we Define their job
and their
limits represent
lley thank you
um thank you representative spillsbury I
I agree with your concerns one of the
things I was looking for as I read this
bill were were caps um and there aren't
any
the what I appreciate about the bill is
that it it feels like it does lay out
some very clear
um things for which employers can be in
reimbursed and those things seem to
largely um align with quality so if
you're reimbursing people to get CPR
training or reimbursing people to get uh
additional education or conference
attendance then you're um supporting
quality daycare which I think is
something that that we want to do and I
I do tend to compare it with um public
education that is provided for children
above age five
um when we give vouchers to those
families we it is is much more wide open
than this so it seems to me that that it
is trying to
um not not only increase the
availability of workers by by supporting
them but increase the quality of those
workers by supporting specifically um
education and when we support worker
healthare obviously they can show up to
work more so I I think that that what
they're supporting is uh very
advantageous um I too would have liked
to see some caps thank
you represent elberger followed by thank
you Mr chair um representative
spillsbury I want to clarify one of the
comments that you made you said there's
no criteria and what types of criteria
were you referring
to well there are eight
different um types of expenditure that
someone could theoretically claim and
get a grant for right and there should
be criteria for each of those eight I
would want to engage you in a discussion
one by one through the eight just give
me one
please well child care tuition
assistance what does that mean go get a
PhD go ahead
uh we have spent very large numbers of
millions of dollars on education Freedom
accounts which at this point have no
caps there's no limit to how many
children can apply for them uh as far as
I can tell there are no criteria for
evaluating the success or lack thereof
of those accounts and we continue to
fund them uh I believe that the
specific uh purposes for the funding
that would come into
this
uh come through this bill are certainly
as well defined and as reasonable as the
way we're approaching the education
Freedom accounts so I believe that we
should be supporting this as well thank
you Mr chair yes um just to speak
specifically to the childcare tuition
assistance that's something that I asked
about um when we had the speakers
yesterday and what that refers to is if
a mother is working in child care and
has a child of her own that needs to go
to child care so she can go work at
child care that that the tuition for her
own child
might be assisted so that she could uh
work and my understanding of child care
tuition discount is if you're working at
a daycare you could tuition your own
child into that daycare at a discount so
that it's it's just the ability of those
people to go to
work okay and yet there's also H not
just
E I can see there's still a lot of
discussion I can also see how this is
playing out I just have a question on
order hold on a second um so I'm going
to take a few more but I also want to be
cognizant of the fact that I want to
start the exec session at 1:30 so I want
to make sure we're not just you know
repeating the same things and yes go
ahead this is just it's not it's kind of
off topic and actually it's relevant to
an off topic discussion so just a
question on Germain amendments versus
non-gain amendments um we're talking
about 126a colon 17 if we were to
amend another section of 126a be it
colon 16 15
whatever does that constitute a non-gain
Amendment or how how how close to the
initial bill do we have to be in order
to be considered
Germain well at the end of the day the
clerk's going to have to make that call
if we're not sure what I've what I've
understood is that if it's in the same
section um then we're okay but if it's a
different section as you're saying then
then we'd have to we'd have to get a a
call on that because if it's not
Germaine we need a public hearing right
thank
you uh representative ORS followed by
fellows yes thank you Mr chair so yeah
I'm surprised the way this conversation
went uh so number one number two I don't
think we're going to advance it but I'm
going to try you know I think part of
the problem we have in our society is we
are the richest Society in the world the
poorest of the poor have the best of
what most of the world would like to
have and as my wife would say if Sarah
Johnson can rais 12 kids in a single
room house you know maybe maybe the
father or the mother needs to stay home
and raise their own kids I mean that's
what my wife and I did and we started a
homebased business and raised our kids I
mean what the you know it's like maybe
we don't need the government do
everything
Jers anything else represented
fellows um I just wanted to say that
with respect to Grants this we could
create this uh fund but we're limiting
where the money could come from because
the federal government would
never um support money for these some of
these it items they would support it for
like hiring new new people but not for
putting money into a retirement plan
into a tax advantage savings account and
when it comes to things like uh tuition
or train training would be great tra to
but you in a Federal grant you'd be more
likely to have a contract with um snhu
or something like that to develop a
program and make get affordable at low
cost or no cost to recruits so this
just and I don't think the federal
government would um approve something
with another entity managing the program
instead of the agency at HHS managing
the program because they pay um for
administrative cost usually with a
percentage so this is really written for
some kind of
specific plan that somebody has in their
mind that we haven't really seen and
don't understand that we could fund it
with State money but I think other
sources would not fit into this so if
I'm understanding you correctly you are
are you agreeing with representative
spillsbury to some extent that there's
too many things just listed here that
aren't well
defined I'm I'm my concern is that there
are too many things list did that make
it restrictive so that it wouldn't
qualify for some sources of Grants okay
thank you representative shamber thank
you Mr chairman I disagree with my
fellow representative here that you're
taking the assumption that grants are
only Federal there are nonprofit grants
there are private individual grants that
can be uh uh uh come into for an
organization there are uh even state
grants that can apply to this I don't
think we should look at it as Federal
that that this
money comes sometimes with strings
attached but that's up to the
organization to decide if they want to
accept that Grant I I just disagree with
your your point of it's all
federal representative Aly thank you um
as I said
before this was written with the
understand standing with the Senate
that the first year they were going to
dump 15 million into a section of HHS
which didn't really know how to handle
it it sounds like um it's taken them
quite a while to write the
rules um and that the next year they
would get it out to a designated ENT
to take care of and they put it together
as what a lot of people in child care
said would be
helpful in their businesses to be able
to keep or
recruit on more workers they they lose
workers with great regularity now and
they have to close down units because of
it um because of that $5 difference but
a lot of the people that go into this
profession want to stay in it and they
um they do they are as women always have
been and some men as well volun and as
we are
volunteers in that are stretching their
budgets to be able to afford to
stay and this would these are things
that would help them to do that there it
isn't complete specification the rules
are supposed to be written next year but
the idea was that there would be Rules
by the time we got around to the 2025
Budget on and that would specify
everything and that the Senate would
again come back and say say we need to
put some money into child care and we
think it should be the same amount
that's what they said last year um but
presumably at that point it would be
more efficiently used than probably will
happen this year so um
that's what this is about which I didn't
understand before I talked with Mary
Jane walner about it but um
you've got to remember we became
a a
um two twers per two worker per Family
household system in this country and
then the pandemic destroyed
that and we have to if in order to get
back to it we've got to have more more
child care for the twers families
especially the twers families that can't
afford to pay $5 more on that are
working in our we're working in our
businesses in our businesses are now
even though we've got a lot of
immigrants who have come in and have
helped to create the surge that we've
got in employment now it apparently
isn't anywhere near
enough so
this this is a major economic drag on
our on our society because we no longer
are a one worker
family but we're acting like we have to
act like one right now because we don't
have
Alternatives this would right loosen the
Alternatives yeah we know
um we've kind of acknowledged there
there's an issue it's a policy issue
that got to this point where were
focused on the the revenue aspect um I
think um are we all set discussing this
this point okay I'll close the work
session on
1611 what are we so um the exec session
is scheduled for
1:30 um the Republicans will cockus here
at
1:00 and hopefully half an hour to to
get lunch
um is enough all right I'll see the
Republicans back here at one o'clock
thank
you
e
um Statewide education property tax and
excess revenue from games of chance and
I will recognize representative PL yes I
move itl on this
bill all right do I have a
second second from
Southworth I know see him down there no
I I have trouble seeing him as well um
would you like to speak to your your
motion yes uh first of all I got a
couple of reasons to itl this first one
is that it's the education property tax
i s to push that all off a while till
till we have a a committee look at the
whole thing and see what the courts uh
do but this this we heard in testimony
that uh this was excess of 6.6 million I
think would come back uh is a a credit
never hit that high I think the highest
it's hit is 5.6 and it's not growing
that fast actually 5.38 5.38 it's moot
in other words yeah that's another
powerful word
moot okay any other
comments seeing none the clerk will take
the role okay chairman chairman janigian
no no represent stting oh okay changing
things around here on me well now that
we have a Vice chair representative
representative DEET yes representative
spillsbury yes representative plots yes
representative sod yes representative
ORS representative roord yes
representative gagy yes representative
Aly yes rep uh representative uh Ames
yes representative Southworth yes
represent Malloy yes representative
shamber yes representative fellows yes
represent Bolton yes representative
elberger yes representative leapley yes
representative cluer yes uh
representative erer that's I got out of
order here sorry about that a
representative papovich Miller yes and
chairman janigian yes 20 to
zero if there's no objections we'll put
that on consent saying none it goes on
consent
close the exact session for hb1
1517 okay we'll now open the exec
session on HB
1193 and I'll uh recognize
representative ORS yes yes thank you Mr
chair I make a motion to
itl Second Mr chair second by
representative shamberg
would you like to speak to your motion
uh yes thank
you uh testimony we've seen no
businesses have uh come requested this
credit and uh also it'll reduce the
general fund I believe at this time is
not
required other
comments seeing none the clerk will take
the
role
uh representative uh ducet
yes representative erery yes
representative Popovich Miller yes
representative spillsbury yes represent
PL votes yes representative sodi yes
representative ORS yes representative
roord yes representative gagy yes
representative Aly yes
representative Ames yes representative
Southworth yes representative Malloy yes
representative shamberg yes
representative
fellows yes representative Bolton yes
elberger yes representative leapley yes
representative cluer yeah and the chair
yes V is 20 to
zero any objection to consent saying
none it'll go on the consent
calendar and I'll close the exec session
on HB
1193 now open the exec session on hb1
14 29 and recognize representative
spillsbury for a motion thank you Mr
chairman I move interim
study do I have a
second second by representa
Aly and would you like to speak to your
motion very brief comments I mean we we
heard that there are big differences
between one Dam and another Dam one
Town's appetite another Town's appetite
Downstream uh possibly there's room for
amending this in a narrower way we know
that the state now can offer a dam but I
think that uh certain towns are looking
for a financing mechanism so we can give
this some more space to shape it and see
it come back next year in a budget
year thank you any other comments seeing
none the clerk oh yes I will just say
I'm passionately for this bill I heard a
lot of discussion that was policy when
it was really just this committee's role
was finance and so I'm I'm not going to
vote in favor of the uh interim study
okay despite that the clerk will call
the role absolutely two different roles
Clerk and U
Advocate uh uh okay the motion being
interim study uh rep uh representative
duet this should be changed in order in
this form representative erery yes
represent papovich Miller yes represent
spillsbury yes represent plat votes yes
no no representative sodi
yes representative ORS even though the
clerk doesn't give a damn
yes representative Rochford yes uh
representative gagy yes representative
Aly representative Ames yes
representative Southworth yes
representative
Malloy yes representative shamberg yes
representative fellos yes representative
Bolton yes representative elberger yes
representative leapley yes
representative cluer yes and the the
chair yes the vote being 19 one and I
won't object to consent that was going
to be my next question
okay so that will go on the consent
calendar and I'll close the exact
session on hb1
1429 I'll now open the exec session on
hb1
1470 and recognize representative
boards thank you Mr chair I'd make a
motion it
do I have a
second second second by representative
ducet would you like to speak to your
motion yes thank you Mr chair uh
currently we have a housing study in
progress uh possibly more than one from
the testimony we've heard I see no need
in duplicating that effort and um I
guess that's enough thank you okay other
comments comments representative
Aly I think we said it in the work
session um this is looking at a
particular issue that is not being
covered at this time and probably won't
be covered for quite some time to come
but since it takes a long time to figure
out the zoning by the special housing
committee
so we think that a
short focused study of just this one
issue could come back again to the
special housing
committee for them to fit into their
General work if necessary but that it it
should provide on more Enlightenment on
the issue that is very important for the
uh lower income parts and the middle
inome parts of our Workforce that
frequently in housing issues get um the
short shift frankly in terms of of
building because construction is a lot
more lucrative to build for the higher
income
sections
okay any more
comments
okay seeing none that clerk will call
the role on itl on Bill 1470
representative the set yes
representative oler yes representative
papovich Miller yes representative
spillsbury yes representative plvs yes
represent sodi yes represent ores yes
representative rord yes representative
gagy yes representative
Aly representative Ames no
representative Southworth no
representative Malloy no Representative
shamberg no representative fellows no
represent Bolton no represent elberger
no Representative leapley no
representative Smith
Audia and uh the
chairman yes the vote is
1010 so I assume it's not going consent
well the motion fails the motion fails
so yeah we
now we don't have to do the why did we
have to
do if if if it's itl fails isn't
automatically OTP no especially when
it's
otpa so no recommendation I
on on Mr clerk I move on HB
1470 ought to pass with an amendment
which has been
provided I could get you the number of
the
amendment uh it Amendment
701h
oh I'll second that motion Mr
chairman okay do we have we already have
a copy of that um yes we all have a copy
of the amendment okay all right I have a
second would you like to speak to your
motion okay who seconded it sorry uh
Rose
shamber
yes and I think I spoke to the motion
just now
okay I don't know if any other represent
leapley would like to representative
leapley um I reviewed the statutory and
study committees that are
currently exist existing and it doesn't
look like there's one that is dealing
with low income and Workforce housing um
and this does not
have an impact um fiscally and I think
everyone in New Hampshire acknowledges
that housing is a crisis so it seems to
me a study would be appropriate at this
time thank
you okay representative ducet just just
for the record I think we discussed in
the work session that we have a special
committee on housing and that's what was
referenced not a specific study
committee
okay so uh anything any
other so this first vote would be on the
amendment what's the amendment number
representative call me
701h uh
701h
yes okay the clerk will call the role
okay on Amendment 701 1 H um
representative
duet no representative uh erery nope
represent Popovich Miller no represent
spillsbury no the clerk votes no uh
representative sodi uh sodi no
representative ores no representative
rord
yes representive uh gagy
no representative
Aly yes representative Ames yes
representative Southworth yes
representative Malloy yes representative
shanberg yes representative fellows yes
representative Bolton yes representative
elberger yes representative leapley yes
uh and uh representative
cluer and the
chair
no
the vote is
11-9 on the
amendment on okay so Mr Mr chairman or
Mr clerk I'm not sure which on to I move
ought to pass with Amendment
7018 is there a
second second by by representative Elber
okay going to keep up here
yeah no
otpa yes
otpa not on the first line there is
it okay
uh so Aly and it was seconded by
represent elberger
elberger uh
okay the clerk will call the rooll when
he's ready yes
sorry okay uh a to pass as amended on
1470 I'll call on Representative ducet
no representative uh h no represent poic
Miller no Representative spillsbury no
representative plat votes no
Representative sodi no represent ORS no
representative Roser no uh
Representative gagy
no uh representative Aly yes
representative Ames yes representative
Southworth yes representative Malloy yes
represent shamber yes represent fellows
yes repr Bolton yes represent elberger
yes represent leapley yes represent
cluder yes and the chair no the vote is
10 so the recommendation it goes uh to
the floor with no
recommendation
okay close the exact session on hp1
1470 each the next one is 1613 we're
going to defer that um until
Monday so next up would be
HB I'll open the session the exec
session on HB 1410 and recognize
representative duet thank you Mr
chairman I move ought to pass on HP 1410
do I have a
second second Mr chairman representative
shamberg seconds
it would you like to speak to your
motion uh just in brief this doesn't
have a fiscal component so should have
been waved
off any other comments seeing none the
clerk will call the
role okay on ought to pass and 14 1910
uh representative ducet yes uh
representative erery yeah representative
papovich
Miller yes representa spillsbury yes
represent PL votes yes representative
sodi yes represent orus yes
representative rord yes representative
Aly uh representative gagy yes
representative Aly
yes represent Ames yes represent
Southworth yes represent Malloy yes
representative shamber yes
representative fellos yes representative
Bolton yes representative elberger yes
representative leapley yes
representative cluder yes and the chair
yes 20 to
Zer any objections to consent seeing
none it'll go on the consent
calendar
and I'll close the exec session on
1410 the next one on our list here hb1
1655 we are also going to defer that
until
Monday so next up is uh HB I'll open the
exact session on HB
1198 and recognize representative sod
for a motion and the motion for that is
OTP do I have a second second Mr
chairman
would you like to speak to your motion
uh yes um uh this gives the state the
opportunity for extra Revenue by staying
open these ex extra days and I think
that's evidenced by the willingness of
uh private uh entities uh and other
states who are allowed the opportunity
stay open as well as a source of profit
thank you any other
comments seeing none I'll ask the clerk
to call the role uh 1198 ought to pass
uh representative ducet yes
representative erery yes representative
popovic Miller yes representative
spillsbury yes representative plot yes
representative sodi yes representative
ores yes representative rord yes
representative gagy yes representative
Aly yes representative Ames yes
representative Southworth yes represent
Malloy yes representative shamber yes
Representative fellos no
represent Bolton yes represent of
elberger yes representative leapley yes
represent of cludia yes and the chair
yes okay the vote is 19 to
one do you have an no objection okay
it'll go on
consent and I will close the exact
session on H got to get more papers I
ran
eight go to
it just gonna
check
fil this is
the
just this goes
to this goes
to
okay what are we about to
do 11
all right now that the clerk has his
paperwork we can proceed and I will open
the exact session on HB
1293 relative to the use of certain
fertilizers on Turf and recognize
representative sodi for a motion the
motion is OTP I have a
second second Mr
chairman thank
you would you like to speak to your
motion yep um being that there's no
fiscal impact here and the policy has
been it's been determined uh let's go
with
it succinct and true
seeing no other comments I'll ask the
clerk to call the role represent duet on
OTP OTP yes uh represent Valery yes
represent papovich Miller yes represent
spillsbury yes represent plfs yes
representative sodi yes represent ORS
yes representative rord yes represent
gagy maywe may we
say
okay
Pard
any representative
Aly representative Ames
yes representative Southworth yes
represent Malloy yes represent shamber
yes representative fellow yeses Bolton
yes represent elberger yes representive
leapley yes representative cluder yes
and the chair yes the vote is 2 to
zero I assume no objections to consent
seeing none it'll go on
consent and I will close the exact
session on
1293 now open the exec session on
hb303 and recognize representative Olie
for a
motion uh 1303 motion ought to pass do I
have a
second
second not much enthusiasm over
here I think we got to we got to spread
the wealth there a little bit
representative shamber representative
elberger I
believe would you like to speak to your
motion representative ol why don't we uh
honor the wishes of the gentleman who
adopted this country and this state is
his home and F through with his last
wishes hard to argue with
that okay seeing no
more comment on that I'll ask the clerk
to call the role on HB
1303 okay represent duet what's the
motion motion is not to pass right
represent duet voted yes represent
oler yeah sandor sanbor sorry I ran out
of these papers R
Siller gagy okay and who else was
substituting here cluder okay got it uh
re okay representative papovich Miller
voted yes rep representative spillsbury
yes representative PL votes yes
representative sodi yes represent ORS
yes representative rord yes represent
gagy yes representative Aly uh excuse
representative Aly yes yes
representative Ames yes repres
Southworth yes representative Malloy yes
representative shamber yes
representative fellows yes
representative Bolton yes representative
elberger yes representative leapley yes
representative cluder yes and the chair
yes the vote is 20 to
zero any objection to consent seeing
none it'll go in consent
count next the next one is
um yeah well let me first close the exec
session on
hb303 and open the exec session on HB
1565 and recognize representative
spillsbury for a motion thank you Mr
chairman I move
OTP
do I have a second
second okay second by representative
Bolton and
um would you like to speak to your
motion or offer amendments or yes I'd
like to offer Amendment
H okay uh do I have a second on that do
yeah I need a second on the amendment
also by both second second by
representative
both all right representative spillsbury
please speak to your Amendment so the
amendment very simply uh corrects an
inadvertent error made in environment
and agriculture at the time this bill
was amended and it reinstates an
effective date 60 days after
passage straightforward
enough okay any seeing no other comments
I'll ask the clerk to call the role on
the amendment on
Amendment ought to pass Amendment
0804 H uh representative du
set is it
04h no no wait a minute it's 08
0874 okay
0874 I
misheard what is it representative
spelsbury can you just say that that one
more time
0874 thank
you okay on Amendment
0874 H corre ought to pass uh
representative uh duet yes
representative
erery yes representative papovich Miller
yes representative uh spillsbury yes
representative PL votes yes
representative yes represent ORS yes
represent of rord yes represent Gagney
yes represent
Aly representative Ames yes
representative Southworth yes
representative Malloy yes representative
shamber yes representative fellos yes
representative Bolton yes representative
elberger yes representative leapley yes
representative cluer yes and the chair
yes the vote is 20 to zero on the
amendment
okay now we have
um the OTP
a so the bill is amended is
non-controversial it passed out of BNA
20 to zero Voice vote on the floor it
simply allows a very small sector of of
individuals making uh uh things like
pickles and salsa at home to avoid a
$350 a year license fee the diminished
license fee revenues are di Minimus
about
$25,000 what's up where do you use the
Minimus I wondered if you heard that I'm
pick I'm picking on the chair who
did yes it means from the
minimum
that's okay any um any other comments
seeing none the clerk will call the
roong ought to pass as amended ought to
pass as amended of
1565 representative duet yes represent
oler yes representative papovich Miller
yes represent spillsbury yes represent
PL votes yes represent sodi yes
represent ORS yes represent rord yes
represent of gagy yes representative
Aly represent Ames yes representative
Southworth yes representative Malloy yes
representative shamberg yes
representative fellos yes representative
Bolton yes representative
elberger yes representative leapley yes
representative cluer yes and the chair
yes 20 to zero any objection to
consent seeing none this will also go on
the consent calendar and I'll close the
exec session for HB
1565 now I will open the exec session
for HB 1709 and recognize representative
Aly for a motion hold on give me a
second okay we'll give the clerk a
second
good okay but I ran out of marked up on
pum we're pushing you to the Limit
all right this is Bill
number what Bill are we taking
179 Mo okay then recognize
representative Al me for a motion
okay and a second from representative
s representative Aly would you like to
speak to your motion yes uh this bill
was amended by the policy committee to
be a simple
commission and um has no fiscal impact
left
okay any other comments seeing none the
clerk will call the
role okay U ought to pass as the motion
uh representative ducet yes
representative uh erery yes
representative papovich Miller yes
representative spillsbury yes
representative PL votes yes
representative
sodi he stepped out
uh representative ores
yes uh representative rord yes
representative uh gagy yes
representative Aly yes representative
Ames yes repres of Southworth yes
represent Malloy yes represent shamber
yes represent fellos yes represent
Bolton yes represent of alberger yes
represent of leapley yes represent of
cler yes and the chair yes and the vote
is 1901 not
voting any objection to consent seeing
none this will also go on
consent okay and uh that pretty much
concludes what we are doing so the clerk
can take a you break mentioned HB well
yeah I'm just so the last one on this
list here is um HB 1611 which we will
push um off as
well so in the um I had to get all
the the schedule in for for Monday I had
to get it in by one o'clock so therefore
not knowing the outcome of these uh you
will see in the calendar that I have
again listed all these bills with the
with the um saying at the top that
anything not finished will be taken up
on Monday so the section the work
session is going to start at 9: :30 on
Monday the 11th the exact session I have
starting at uh 10:30 um on the 11th and
as I said you'll see all the bills
listed and that's the reason why I had
to put it in before I knew the
results yeah maybe you did but could you
ask the clerk if he would accept a
minimization sure I can check
yeah okay okay anyone have any
questions no questions then I will see
you on
Monday thank
you I didn't introduce myself
John enjoy serving in the house your
first ter oh your second oh I'm sorry
it's my 16th turn
wow